IN TO THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE STATE OF HATE THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND I'M
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RICHARD BLOOM.
AND AM HONORED TO SERVE AS CHAIR
OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT SELECT
COMMITTEE. THIS EVENING OUR
TOPIC IS THE CHANGING FACE OF
EXTREMISM. SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN
WITH HELD SEVERAL HEARINGS AND
EVENTS ON THE CURRENT STATE OF
HATE WITH DIFFERENT POINTS OF
FOCUS AT EACH HEARING. ALTHOUGH
WE'VE COVERED DIFFERENT TOPICS
OVER THE YEARS A COMMON THREAD
REMAINS HATE CRIMES AND OTHER
FORMS OF TARGETED VIOLENCE SEEM
ONLY TO BE TRENDING UPWARD. I'M
SAD TO REPORT THAT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WAS THE WORST YEAR OVERALL
FOR HATE CRIMES SINCE.TWO
THOUSAND ONE. OUR BIGGEST
CONCERNS ARE SHARED BY AB HAVE
BEEN INFORMED BY LEADING EXPERTS
IN THE FIELD. SO FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S A RISE IN LOAN ACTORS
THAT COMMIT VIOLENT ACTS THAT
SUBSCRIBE TO WHITE NATIONALIST
IDEOLOGY BUT WHO ARE NOT
NECESSARILY ACTING ON BEHALF OF
A PARTICULAR GROUP. THERE'S ALSO
THE PROBLEM OF POLITICAL
REGIONALIZATION. WE HAVE HOT
BUTTON LARGE SCALE ISSUES THAT
ARE PLAYING OUT AT LOCAL LEVELS
WHERE THEY HAVEN'T BEFORE. WE
THINK TARGETED VIOLENCE AND
AGGRESSION BEYOND TRADITIONAL
HATE CRIME TARGETS PEOPLE X. GOT
LIKE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ELECTED OFFICIALS
AND OTHER CIVIL SERVANTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE INTERRELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
TARGETED AGGRESSION AND VIOLENCE
SOCIAL MEDIA AND FREE SPEECH IS
QUICKLY GROWING. OVER THE YEARS
WE'VE HOSTED THESE HEARINGS ONE
THING BECAME ABUNDANTLY CLEAR.
WE NEED A PERMANENT STATEWIDE
CENTRALIZED BODY NOT UNLIKE THE
SELECT COMMITTEE TO TRACK AND
MONITOR HATE CRIMES TRENDS AND
TO RECOMMEND POLICY SOLUTIONS TO
THE LEGISLATURE. SO I'M GRATEFUL
THAT THIS PAST OCTOBER GOVERNOR
NEWSOM SIGNED ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX WHICH WAS MY
LEGISLATION THAT FORMALLY
ESTABLISHES A PERMANENT
COMMISSION ON THE STATE OF HATE
SOMETHING OF WHICH I AM SO PROUD
AND IN THE MONTHS TO COME THAT
COMMISSION WILL. FORM AND THE
MEMBERS WILL BE APPOINTED TO IT
AND ULTIMATELY BEGIN TO HOLD
HEARINGS. BUT UNTIL THAT TAKES
PLACE THE SELECT COMMITTEE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THIS MUCH NEEDED
WORK. WE HAVE A FULL PROGRAM
AHEAD OF US THIS EVENING SO-
JUST BEFORE WE GET STARTED I'M
GOING TO TURN THE MIKE OVER TO
MY GOOD FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE
MIGUEL SANTIAGO. WHO IS GOING TO
WELCOME US INTO HIS DISTRICT
WHERE WE ARE HOSTING THE HEARING
THIS EVENING AND AFTER THAT
YOU'LL HEAR FROM MY OTHER GOOD
FRIEND WHO'S HERE THIS EVENING-
ASSEMBLER ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELOISE
RAMOS- WHO SERVED ON THE
COMMITTEE ALONG. WITH MYSELF AND
OTHERS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM AND MISS-
MAJORITY LEADER REYES FOR COMING
DOWN TO THE DISTRICT AND HOSTED
A PART OF AN ANTI WHITE WHY IT'S
TIMELY AND- WHAT'S IMPORTANT
THAT- YOU RECOGNIZED AND HOSTED
IN IN. OUR DISTRICT BECAUSE-
MOST OF YOU KNOW THAT DURING THE
LAST SUMMER WE SAW SOME OF THE
MOST- HORRIFIC ACTS- AND I
CALLED OF VIOLENCE EVEN THOUGH
FROM A MOVE OR VERBAL AS IT
RELATES TO. AP I HATE. YOU KNOW
OR WE SAW. IN THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT HAS LITTLE TOKYO AND
CAREER COUNT. AT WE SAW- WE
THOUGHT EVERYTHING FROM FLOWERS-
BEING SAID. TO A KOREAN SENIORS
WERE WALKING ON THE STREET TWO.
BOTTLES OR OR SODA- PHILIPPINE
THROWN- WE SAW SOME VIOLENCE
WITH THEM HITTING AND THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN INCIDENTS AND
A CRIME I RECOGNIZE- BUT NEVER
DID WE EVER THINK THAT AFTER.
ALL WE'VE GONE. IN CALIFORNIA IN
PARTICULAR LOS FANS OF HER
PROGRESS A LOT HINGES COULD SEE
SOMETHING. LIKE WHAT WE SAW HERE
RIGHT IN OUR OWN BACKYARD. AND
IT'S WITH HEARTFELT- PAYMENT
RELEASE THAT I HAD FIT WE SAW
THIS ALL ACROSS LOS ANGELES OR-
EVEN IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT SOME
OF THE REPORTS- RECENTLY WERE
LOS ANGELES. CITY IS WHERE MOST
OF THE- EIGHT- AXE AND CRIME
HAPPENED- AND IT'S DISHEARTENING
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW THAT
WE'VE GONE A LOT THAT WE MOVED A
LOT FOR- IN THIS AREA- WE FOUND
A LOT BEHIND- AT THE SAME TIME.
AND ARE AREAS FELT THE GUN
DEBATE. I MEAN I DON'T KNOW HOW
OFF THE FACE A. N. N. AND IT
WASN'T JUST ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE
SAYING IT BECAUSE WE THOUGHT
PEOPLE FROM OUR OWN CULTURE AS
WELL WE'VE GOT ONLY AND WE DID
IT'S PAINFUL TO HAVE TO SAY BUT
IT'S- BUT IT'S TRUE. WHAT WE SAW
IN ONE INSTANCE A AND IT WAS
WELL DOCUMENTED WERE- API WOMAN
WAS ORDERING FOOD. AND WAS BE
RATED. AND VIOLENTLY YELLED AT-
ALMOST PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED
WHILE ENTIRE RESTAURANT- ITS
EMPLOYEES AND ITS MANAGER SAT
THERE AND JUST WATCH THAT
HAPPENED NOT TOO FAR AWAY FROM
HERE. YOUR WE THOUGHT A
GENTLEMAN- BEAT UP IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE STREET. WHERE WE SAW.
OVER AND OVER- VERBALLY ABUSED
OR PHYSICALLY ABUSED- I'VE I
CAN'T EVEN I BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION TODAY
TO BE FRANK WITH YOU I MEAN I
THAT WE EEL LIKE WE'VE GONE SO
FAR YET WE HAVEN'T GONE THAT FAR
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT- ART.
DISTRICT TOOK ACTION AND IT
WASN'T. IT WAS A GRASSROOTS
MOVEMENT REALLY WRE WE JOIN THE
MOVEMENT WITH AT LEAST IT WOULD
JOIN THE MOVEMENT OF BOTH ALL
THE WAY FROM KOREATOWN TO LITTLE
TOKYO IN AND MARCHING AND
CALLING TO ACTION IN AND
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZING NONPROFIT
ORGANIZING IN CARAVANS UP AND
DOWN TRYING TO SHUT THE ALARM OF
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED- AT A VERY
BASIC CHORDS THAT YOU CAN'T
TOLERATE IT AT ANY LEVEL AND YOU
CAN'T TOLERATE IT NO MATTER WHAT
THE AGES WHETHER A KID IS. FIVE
YEARS OF AGE OR EIGHTEEN OR
FORTY FIVE YOU CALL IT OUT FOR
WHAT IT IS- AND YOU STOP IT WERE
ATTACKED N. YOU CAN'T STAND TO
BE AN INNOCENT BYSTANDER- WHAT
WE FOUND VERY EFFECTIVE. IS THAT
WOULD YOU MAKE IT NOT COOL WHEN
YOU CALLED OUT FOR WHAT IT IS
WHEN YOU SEE SOMEBODY DOING IT
THAT SOMEONE ACROSS THE STREET.
AND YOU WALK ACROSS THE STREET
ENJOYING THAT PERSON IS
SOLITARY. IT DOES HELP. AND I
THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IS- THAT
WHILE WE PUSH FOR ALL THE
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES AND WE
SHOULD AND WHY WE PUSH FOR THE
BUDGET. I THAT WE HAVE IN IN
THERE WAS A PIECE- THAT FUNDED-
STOP API- WHICH WAS- WHAT WHICH
IS FUNDED THROUGH UCLA THAT THE
PROGRAM THAT I KNOW. YOU WORKED
ON IN THIS REYES WORKED ON WILL
PUSH VERY HARD TO DO WHICH
COLLECTS THE DATA THEN THEN
QUANTIFIES OUR ABILITY TO SAY
THIS IS REALLY A PROBLEM WE KNOW
THE PUMP IT'S GOT QUALIFIED IN
DATA. AND WE KNOW THAT FOR EVERY
PER THING THAT IS REPORTED.
THERE ARE LOTS. MORE THAT WERE
NOT. I THINK WHAT WHAT WHAT-
WHAT WE LEARNED IS IT IS WE'VE
GOT A JOINT FOLLOWED AND CALLED
OUT FOR WHAT IT IS WHEN IT
HAPPENS YOU CAN BE AN INNOCENT
BYSTANDER AND THAT THAT HAS BEEN
THE LARGEST- I THINK. ONE OF THE
LARGEST MOVEMENT TO SUPPRESSION
TO THAT SORT OF HATE. IS THAT
WOULD YOU SEE IT HAPPEN YOU HAVE
TO CALL IT OUT YET THE SHEEN YOU
HAVE TO STOP IT NO MATTER WHO IT
IS. NO MATTER WHETHER IT'S- YOUR
OWN OR SOMEBODY WHO YOU LOVE YOU
JUST HAVE TO STOP. AND IT GOES A
LONG WAYS TO DO SO. AND THAT'S
WHY I THINK THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
WHEN THE RUBBER HITS THE ROAD
IT'S EITHER TYPE OF ACTIONS. THE
PEOPLE FEET TOWARD AND IF. IT
WOULD RESULT IN ITS REAL
MOVEMENT IT'S REAL STOPPING-
THIS HORRIBLE DIEASE OF HATE
THAT WE'VE NOW SEEN IN OUR STATE.
THANK YOU FOR DOING IF I. A
LITTLE LONGER THAN I WANTED TO
BUT BUT I BUT IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THINK THAT YOU'RE
DOING THIS THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WILL
HEAR FROM MAJORITY LEADER RAMOS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION.
IT'S BEEN A PRIVILEGE TO SERVE.
WITH OUR CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RICHARD BLOOM. ON THIS
COMMITTEE- AT THE LAST COMMITTEE
HEARING WE HAD AT CAL STATE SAN
BERNARDINO. WE HAD PROFESSOR
BRIAN LEVIN WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
TODAY- HIS. RESEARCH AND HIS
BODY OF WORK. IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AS WE STUDY THE VERY
ISSUE. AND WE TRY TO FIND
SOLUTIONS. TO HATE CRIMES.
TODAY'S PARTICULAR HEARING
HAVING TO DO WITH THE CHANGING
FACE OF EXTREMISM IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US I- AT THE
END SAMBAR TO DINO- AS MANY OF
WHAT MANY OF US KNOW ON DECEMBER
SECOND TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE
SUFFERED A TERRORIST ATTACK- TWO
INDIVIDUALS KILLED FOURTEEN. AND
INJURED TWENTY TWO SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY EMPLOYEES WHO WERE
ATTENDING A HOLIDAY PARTY. IT
WAS HATRED IS HATRED THAT THAT
BROUGHT BROUGHT THIS ABOUT AT
THIS EVENT AS WELL AS COUNTLESS
OTHER HATE CRIMES TO CONTINUE
ACROSS OUR STATE ACCOUNT COUNTRY
CONTINUE TO BE AN ISSUE THE
SEEMS TO EVADE A SOLUTION. AND
THAT IS WHY HEARING SUCH AS THIS
ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT SO THAT
WE CAN TALK ABOUT IT AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE- MR SANTIAGO SHARED.
THIS IS A HORRIBLE DISEASE OF
HATE THIS IS NOT JUST SOMETHING
THAT CAN EXIST AND IT'S GOING TO
GO AWAY IT IS A DISEASE WE HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO DIAGNOSE IT AND BE
ABLE TO FIND WAYS TO REACH.
SOLUTIONS I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GAIN THAT VALUABLE
INFORMATION THAT INSIGHTS INTO
THE TRENDS THAT RELATE TO HATE
AND EXTREMISM. I'M ALSO HOPEFUL
THAT WE'RE GOING TO FIND
SOLUTIONS. AT TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH COLLEAGUES LIKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO MAKES A DIFFERENCE-
BOTH ARE COMMITTED TO MAKING
SURE THAT WE LIVE IN A BETTER
SOCIETY AND PART OF THAT IS
IDENTIFYING THE PROBLEM AND DOES
MISTER BLOOM WHO SAID THEN
TRYING TO FIND THE SOLUTIONS.
FOR LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION ON THESE ISSUES AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING. THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR- ELOQUENT COMMENTS. A
COUPLE OF QUICK BUT IMPORTANT
HOUSEKEEPING NOTES BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR SPEAKERS FOR THE
ARE THOSE WHO ARE PRESENT HERE
IN THE ROOM WE ASK THAT YOUR
FACE MASK REMAIN ON FOR THE
DURATION OF THE HEARING. AND AT
THE CONCLUSION OF OUR LAST
SPEAKER'S PRESENTATION WHICH
SHOULD BE- A LITTLE BIT AFTER
SIX PM WE WILL BEGIN OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD WHERE YOU WILL BE
INVITED TO VOICE YOUR OPINIONS
AND CONCERNS RELATING TO THE
SUBJECT MATTER OF THIS HEARING.
I WILL PROVIDE A PHONE AND
NUMBER AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE
PRESENTATION THAT IT WILL ALSO
BE AVAILABLE ON SCREEN AS WE
OPEN UP TO PUBLIC COMMENTS. WE
HAVE A FULL AGENDA THIS EVENING
WITH EXPERT PANELISTS I THINK
YOU ARE. GOING TO BE AMAZED AT
THE DETAIL THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
HEAR TONIGHT FROM OUR SPEAKERS.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
PROFESSOR BRIAN LEVIN OF CSU
SAMBAR TO DINO. FOLLOWED BY DR
HEIDI BERWICK OF THE GLOBAL
PROJECT AGAINST HATE AND
EXTREMISM. SEAMUS HUGHES OF
GEORGE WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY'S
PROGRAM ON EXTREMISM AND FINALLY
NIKKI SAYING FROM THE SICK
COALITION. AND WITHOUT FURTHER
ADO I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
PROFESSOR BRIAN LEVIN WHO STARTS
OFF WITH THE LATEST FBI
STATISTICS AND IF I COULD ASK
EACH OF THE SPEAKERS TO GIVE
JUST A LITTLE INTRODUCTION OF
YOURSELVES- A LITTLE BIT OF YOUR
BACKGROUND BUT- THAT WOULD BE-
MOST WELCOME. PROFESSOR LEVIN
IT'S- GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN EVEN
THOUGH I CAN'T SEE YOU. CAN YOU
HEAR US PROFESSOR LEVIN. I AM I
AM HOLD ON JUST HOLD ON ONE
SECOND WE'RE- HE WANTS. HIM OUT.
GET YOUR. YEAH- DID YOU SEE THE
SCREEN. YEAH ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH MY SON DOESN'T TRUST ME
WITH THE REMOTE ALL WE WANT
YESTERDAY I REALLY WANT TO BLAST
THROUGH ONLINE LATIN DIRECTOR
FOR OVER TWENTY SHOULD MONITOR
RESEARCH IS AREA. THIRTY FIVE
PLUS YEARS AND WHAT WHAT A
PLEASURE I'M ONE OF THE DAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOD BLESS YOU
WHAT A FOOL- ACTUALLY- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANDY I WILL GUIDE YOU
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING AND I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT OUR HOMETOWN. ALL STAR.
THANK YOU WILL FOR YOUR THIS
WELL I'M TRYING. TO BE BECAUSE
WE DO KNOW OF TIME ON THE BOTTOM
LINE. WE'RE ARAMBULA VERSION OF
FLYING THREAT- DO NOTHING ENTER
THIS IS IT WILL GO SOMETIME WE
SEE INCREASES IT MAY ALL LIKE
SOME WE SEE AN INCREASE IN ONE
PROGRAM FOR NOW WHY SHOULD
APPROACH AND FORMER IF YOU
HOLDEN MOST BUT NOT ONLY COUNTY
THREAT AND WE'RE SEEING WORKING
ALTHOUGH THEY'RE ABLE INCREASING
RISE FROM WIRELESS SELFISH YOU
HARNESS. INTERNATIONALLY WHAT
ARE YOU GOING TO. WELL THE ARE
YOU THREAT THROUGH MORE.
HOSPITALS SHE YOU WHO'S YOUR A
LOT OF WORK ON IS YOUR- ALL HAS
INCREDIBLE BACK. IT WOULD SORT
OF THE LEAST AND I SO WE USUALLY
ABOUT THE- WHAT WOULD TOM. ALL
POLITICAL. AND THREATS POSSIBLE.
NATION THAT UPPED FOR ALL THESE
WILL RISE BUT A LOT IT WILL
MATTER ITSELF WE- BUT WE SEE
THIS WE SHOULD ALL RIGHT TO COME
TO THE- LEFT CYCLE. WHAT YEAR
MERCILESSLY THE SHOW DOWN A LOT
OF GALLAGHER. WE SHOULD. A
DECLINE IN ADDITION ON. THE SAME
DAY. WE'RE USED WE SAW ALL FIRST
IN YEARS OF BY HARD LEFT. I HAD
JUST YEAR WE SHOULD REMEMBER TO
THE BUYER OUT THIS YEAR. AGAIN
HERE WHAT WE SEE UP YONDER REYES
TALKING ON FOR DURING THE HOME
MOMS THE STOCK ATTACK. AND I'M
FOR. OF WE SHOULD. ADOPT TO- WE
ARE A LITTLE LESS. STRUCTURE AND
I'M A LONG OF PEOPLE WE REALLY
TYPE OF THE EXTREME ALL OF VIEWS
SUB. I AM USUALLY THE FOREIGN
WOULD USE ALL I. YOUR FROM
RUSSIAN AND THIS. NATIONALLY AS
WELL AS YOU CAN WE SHOWED RUN
WHAT. LET MONTH PROFESSOR
LEVIN'S- CAN I CAN I ASK YOU A
YOU SAID YOU'RE IS HELP YOU WITH.
US DECK- CAN- YES YES. CAN YOU
CAN YOU IF FILL THE SCREEN. I
SURE TO SEE IF WE CAN. SOME OF
LOTUSLIVE SHOW UP AT IT. ANY
CLOSER WRITE SIDE KNOW ABOUT ME
STATION THAT PRESENTATION FOR IS
SHOWING FINANCIAL DISCLOSURE.
WHY YOUR WARM. GEN WE IT IS ON
THE TOP RIGHT YEAH YEAH SEE TO
THE RIGHT RECESSED LIGHT SO
STROLL OVER TO THE RIGHT BY.
ANIMATION SHOWING JOHN. JORDAN
WE'RE AND YOU'RE A POWER POINT
PRESENTATION WE ARE TIED TO THAT
AS PRESENTATION FOR YES SCOLDED
I GOT BUT IT IS HARDER DOWN THE
ROAD YOU'LL DEALS LIKE ZERO. OUR
HEY COULD DECIDE- BUTTON. RATES
START FEELING THAT WE'RE ALL-
OKAY AND IN GO TO PLAY FROM LAW.
ALL RIGHT HERE WE GO- AND THE
LEADER. JESSE IT SO LET. HEY
MAXIS. IT IS. HELLO. IT IS ALL
RIGHT WITH WHAT WE WERE DOING. I
DON'T THINK IT'S SHOWING ON THE
MAYBE THAT'S A GOOD IDEA. YES
THEY PUT IT BACK OKAY OKAY. DID
YOU ORDER THE QUANTITY. JUST
APPLYING TO THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND LOCAL ENTITIES AS WELL SURE
WE'RE SEEING NOT ONLY THIS BROAD
ANALYZED LAURIE WE'RE SEEING
ALSO PLAYING OUT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WHAT FUTURE. CRIME. REALLY
WANT TO TRY AND- A LOT OF THE
STUFF WE'RE GOING. AS WE SPEAK
AND HEAR DIVERT ON THE ONE YOU
THE- MACRO FOR. IF SURE YOU'RE-
BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT. WE'RE
GETTING THAT BACK US BUT IN A
VERY. EIGHT SIXTY THREE. WELL
YEAR WOULD BE ONE OF THE YEAR
EVER. FIRST STEP SHE- OUR THE
MORE. BY THE WAY WILL NOT CRUEL.
AS FORWARD EXACTLY YEAH ARE
STILL SORTING THROUGH BUT I
THINK IT AFFECTED YOUR WORST
DATA AND YOU. THE WORST MONTH
SHE IN THE YEAR AND THAT WAS
COOL WITH DID YOU LLOYD KILLING.
YOUR LOOKING AT A DON'T WORK.
IMPORTANT FOR RIGHT NOW YOUR
FOUR DR PRICE WE SHORTEN. IT
CHECK YOUR ALL WELL WELL THE TOP
TWO RUNS WHEN THEY- AGAIN HERE
WERE. FORWARD FOR FOUR ONE MORE.
CALIFORNIA LAW IN AND YOU WERE
NOT IF YOU WERE BUT WE ARE.
INCREASES ALL AGES CRIME ALL FOR
FORTY ONE AS IN PLAY BUT A LOT
OF WAS THE FIRST SURE SHE STILL
SEEING A LITTLE WE- A G. ALL WE
IS A VERY GOOD. GO UP A BIT
SHOCKING COURT REFUSED YOU'RE
ACTUALLY LA WE WERE SHE ABOUT
WERE. THAN WHAT WE SAW IT THE
FIRST. IN THREE WE SHOULD MAY
CONFLICT WHEN WHAT ARE HELLO OF
STUFF GOING ON I WANT END WITH
THIS WE HAVE TO HAVE THE BEST
EMAIL. ONE OF THE WE SHOW IN WE
SAW INCREASES IN MANY. RACIALLY
ACROSS BOARD. WOW. WELL WHITE
WITH GET ON THE HALL MONTH YOU
EVEN BROWN MORE APRIL FORMALLY.
ALL RIGHT IT HOT AND DEATHS ALSO
SEE TIMED TO STATE STATE MAY IT
IN- MARCH WHAT WAS INCLUDING THE
PROVIDE SO WHAT WE NEED TO WHAT
WAS FOR WITH ME HERE TO APPEAL
TO THE BETTER IS OR NEED. AND
ARE SUCH IT IS. COMPLAIN WILL
POLITICAL WHICH AGAIN IS ON THE
HORIZON AND ONE THING THAT WE
SHOULD. CRY ACTUALLY A LOT OF.
TO COME DURING THE PEAK. WILL
CONFLICTION. DOMESTIC POLITICS
AS WELL AS IT. JOHN WAS WHICH WE
BELIEVE WILL ALL RISE ACROSS A
VARIETY. OF WAYS. AND I. THANK
YOU FELT FOR A- FOR YOUR AND FOR
ALL THAT AND TO YOU AGAIN FOR
ALL OF YOUR ADVOCACY ON A. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY I DON'T THINK- I
DON'T THINK IT'S A
UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY THAT- I
WITHOUT YOUR HELP THAT BILL
WOULD NOT A BECOME A REALITY-
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM DR HEIDI
BARRACK OF THE GLOBAL PROJECT
AGAINST HATE. AND EXTREMISM. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LET ME-
SUCH A PLEASURE FOR ME TO BE
HERE TODAY LET ME JUST QUICKLY
SHARE MY SCREEN. OKAY HOPEFULLY
THAT IS FUNCTIONING CORRECTLY-
SO MY NAME IS. F. INTO DR
ELEVEN. HE MIGHT BURKE AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY AS THAT IS VERY
SUBTLE FOR PERSONAL REASONS I
WAS BORN AND RAISED IN PALM
SPRINGS CALIFORNIA IT WASN'T FOR
THE SAN MARINO ROTARY CLUB I
DON'T THINK I WOULD BE ABLE TO
GET MY PHD THEY HELP THEM PAY
FOR MY DISSERTATION RESEARCH SO
IT'S SPECIAL TO BE HERE- I'M THE
CO FOUNDER OF THE GLOBAL PROJECT
ANYTHING EXTREMISM WHICH MONITOR
TWICE PURPOSES IN EXTREMIST
GROUPS. AND ABLE TO THE THINGS
WERE TRANSNATIONAL PERSPECTIVE
FOR MORE THAN TWO DECADES I'VE
BEEN RESEARCHING AND PUBLISHING
ON THE FAR RIGHT AND OTHER FORMS
OF EXTREMIST ACTIVITY AND I LIKE
THE FEELING HE'S TODAY ABOUT THE
CHANGING NATURE OF HATE NEW S.
TO SYMBOLIZE FEW YEARS AND
THROUGH THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
WITNESSED TERRIBLE TERRORIST
ATTACKS IN RECENT YEARS WRITING
HATE CRIMES AS I SAID DR LET ME
JUST TALK ABOUT. RAPIDLY
CHANGING IN RECENT YEARS USING
THE RISE OF NEW TYPES OF THREATS
VIOLENCE INSPIRING CONSPIRACY
MOVEMENTS A BURGEONING H.
GOVERNMENT PARAMILITARY MOVEMENT
THIS AND RESPONSIBLE FOR
CONSIDERABLE VIOLENCE AND IT
BECOME INCREASINGLY ANTI
IMMIGRANT NEEDS MOSLEM. SO
STARTING AROUND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS IS A
PICTURE OF THE STERILIZED
SYNAGOGUE IN PITTSBURGH THAT IS
ON THE WAY BUT WHEN ACTORS
ATTACKS BEGAN TO PICK UP COURSE
THERE WAS A DIFFERENT TACK AS
WELL IT HOW A CALIFORNIA. BUT
AND WE HAD A SERIES OF THESE
HIGH DEMANDS THE L. PASO
WALMART'S UNITS TIMELINE AND
THEY'RE OFTEN ARE ATTACKS ON
JEWS OR MUSLIMS AND MOTIVATED BY
THE RADIOLOGY THE GREAT
REPLACEMENT THIS IDEA THAT WHITE
AMERICANS ARE SOMEHOW BEING
FORCIBLY REPLACED USUALLY THE
HANDS OF A JURY CONSPIRACY. BY
MUSLIMS REFUGEES HAD OTHER
IMMIGRANTS I THIS IS JUST AN
AMERICAN PROBLEM THE SAME KINDS
OF ATTACHED WITH A BY THE SAME
IDEAS THAT HAPPENING WORLDWIDE
ACTUALLY THE CHRISTCHURCH NEW
ZEALAND MARCH SHOOTINGS WERE
DRIVEN BY THE SAME IDEAS. SO
THOSE TWO WERE A COUPLE OF TAX
IN GERMANY'S IS A WORLDWIDE
PROBLEM AT THIS PARTICULAR WHITE
SUPREMACIST THINKING THIS RIGHT
REPLACING THE CONSPIRACY THEORY
EXTENT ENTERING INTO MAIN
MAINSTREAM CIRCLES. WE ALSO HAD
RISE ANOTHER MOVEMENT THAT IS
INVOLVED IN A LOT OF LOAN AFTER
VIOLENCE SO CALLED INCEL
MOVEMENT OR FOR A VOLUNTARILY
CELIBATE THIS IS A MISOGYNISTIC
MOVEMENT AND AVAILABLE TOOLS TAX
ON WOMEN IN THE UNITED STATES
DEADLY ATTACKS. IN THE UNITED
STATES AS WELL AS ABROAD BY
PEOPLE. MOTIVATED BY THESE IDEAS.
SO IT LOGICAL LOW AFTER RILEY
THAT IS A- WE HAVE HAD AT THE
SAME TIME AS WELL ONE OF THE FEW
GROWING THESE ARE HAPPENING HEY
CRIMES. IS A DOCTOR TO TALK
ABOUT WE A RISE CONSIDERS YOU-
IN A WAY IT HAS BEEN THE CASE IN
THE- THIS. AND HE IS A WENT ON A
TEAR THIS SORT OF MUNI VERY
BELIEVES THAT. DEMOCRATS AND-
STAR OR TRY YOU KNOW GET ANY THE
CHILD TRAPPED. THIS THIS MOVE
WHICH IS OUT IS. INSPIRING BY
THE FBI DIDN'T EVEN EXIST UNTIL
TWENTY SIXTEEN AT THIS POINT IN
THE MOVEMENT OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE SPREAD ACROSS THE
INTERNET IN OTHER COUNTRIES AS
FAR AWAY AS JAPAN. AND IS
EMBLEMATIC OF HOW THE WAITED WEB
FUNCTIONS HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED HOUSING IS IDEAS AND
PROBABLY HAVE ALL SORTS NOT IT
IS WISE TO REMEMBER THIS IS A
CONSPIRACY STYLE. CAN SPREAD.
AND BECOME A RECRUITING TOOL AND
RADICALIZED LOTS AND LOTS OF
PEOPLE AGED EXTREMIST MOVEMENTS
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
IS CONCERNING HERE'S WERE
FIGHTING IN THE IRAQI CIRCLES IN
A VERY VERY YOUNG KIDS. THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD ARE. GETTING
SUCKED INTO THESE WORLDS. I
THERE- OTHER USERS HERE OF
COURSE ALONG WITH YOU ONSITE. A
TELLS AND PAST AROUND THE BACK.
AROUND THE FAIR OF OUR- AND IN A
VERY. OTHER SIMILAR. AND ALL
WHICH YOU LEAD TO SERIOUS REAL
WORLD KIND OF THE DRIVERS OF
DRAFT. HATE CRIMES AND OTHER
PROBLEMS. SO I JUST. CHAU HERE-
SO DATA FROM CENTER FOR DISEASE
AND STUDIES THAT MAKES THE POINT
THAT THE GENERAL TERRORIST
ATTACKS THE DEBATE HAPPENING
RECENTLY AT THE TAIL END OF THIS
IS TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY HAVE LARGELY COMING FROM
THE VIOLENT FAR RIGHT BUT NOT
EXCLUSIVELY ALSO BETTER THE
HOBBIT COMING FROM THE FAR LEFT
WE JUST ROUTE AT INTERNATIONAL
CRUISE BUT REALLY IN RECENT
YEARS OUR BIG PROBLEM HAS BEEN.
FAR RIGHT EXTREMISTS. YOUR WORK.
FOR TWENTY YEARS THE SOUTHERN
POVERTY LAW CENTER AND ONE OF
MY- RESPONSIBILITIES WAS
PRODUCING THE SPLC'S. HATE MAP.
AN INTERESTING INCIDENT
HAPPENING IN TERMS OF HATE
GROUPS THESE ARE GROUPS THAT-
HAPPY HOLIDAYS EXPRESS. SHIP OR
OTHER WEBSITES TO DENIGRATES
WHOLE OTHER CLASSES OF PEOPLE SO
THE LITTLE FOR EXAMPLE ALL JEWS
ALL BLACK AND SO ON ONE OF THE
TRENDS THAT WE'RE SEEING IT IS
THE NUMBER OF HATE GROUPS IS
ACTUALLY STARTING TO FALL OFF.
BECAUSE THESE MOVEMENTS ARE
BECOMING NETWORKS NOT
ORGANIZATIONS THERE ARE MOVING
ONLINE AND PEOPLE AREN'T
NECESSARILY GOING TO BE HARD
DURING THAT ORGANIZATIONS. IN
THE FUTURE. AB YOU EVERYTHING'S
HAPPEN IN THE ON SAY. AND IT IS
ALL APPEALING I MEAN JUST LOOK
ACT BROKEN OF PEOPLE WHO ARE TO
THE IDEA OF THE STATE. WHEN
APRIL ARMIES READING TACK
PLATFORMS WHICH IS BECOME
SOMEWHAT LESS THE CASE IN RECENT
YEARS IS PLACES LIKE FACEBOOK
AND TWITTER AT HANSON D.
PLATFORMING THE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS. IN CANCERS ZERO.
SO JUST IN A LOT COUPLE YEARS
AND SEEN. NUDE MOVEMENTS COME
OUT OF NOWHERE ONE EXAMPLE OF
THIS IS THE BLUE VOICE MOVEMENT.
IF IT IS NOT EXACTLY A HIGHLY
ORGANIZED SET OF PEOPLE THEIR
CELEBRATIONS SAY AIMS TO SORT OF
BRING THE END OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM. AND IT INVOLVES AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF VIOLENCE-
BUT KEY MEMBERS OF THE LITTLE
BOYS KILLED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS IN OPEN IN TWENTY
TWENTY. THEY'RE TEMPTED TO
BOMBER- SOCIAL JUSTICE MOVEMENTS
LAPLAND MATTER PROTESTS IN LAS
VEGAS AND WERE PAINFULLY HIGH
BUT THEY'RE ALSO CONNECTED TO A
LOT OF VIOLENCE OR OTHER
EXPLORATIONS GROUPS. THAT ARE
RELATIVELY NEW IN TERMS OF WHAT
ANYONE FORMED GROUPS LIKE THE
BASE WHICH IS. AN ENGLISH
TRANSLATION OF ARCADIA SO IT
WILL BE SEEN AS A KIND OF
QUICKLY FORMING NEW TYPES OF
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE ACT RIGHT
WING EXTREMISTS AND WHITE
SUPREMACISTS FAITH. AND A LOT OF.
VIOLENCE CONNECTED TO THOSE
GROUPS. THIS ANOTHER EXAM OF A
WORKING TERMS CARE ATTACK BUT
NOW ALL IN TWENTY. AND YOU WILL
SEE HOW. THE VICE OR RIGHT HAS
HAS SPIKED DURING THAT PERIOD OF
TIME. A LOT OF THIS HAS TO DO
WITH REACTION AMONG THE FAR
RIGHT TO THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
PROTESTS THERE WERE ALL KINDS OF
TERRIBLE THINGS. PERPETRATED BY
RIGHT WING EXTREMISTS LIKE CAR
TAX DURING THOSE EVENTS NOT JUST
ABOUT THE ATTEMPTED BOMBING THAT
I JUST MEN BENJAMIN BUT LOTS OF
LOTS. WE ALSO DECIDE TWENTY
TWENTY GROUPS LIKE THE PROUD
BOYS OF THE SCIENTIFIC
ORGANIZATIONS BRUTALIZED.
THINKING EXPLICITLY ANTI MOSLEM.
ARM THAT CAME OUT ONTO THE
STREETS IN HUGE NUMBERS INVOLVED
THEMSELVES INCREASINGLY VIOLENT
COUNTER PROTESTS OR PROTESTS
THEY THEMSELVES HELD. IT THERE
WAS A LOT OF STREET FIGHTING
INVOLVED AND- IT'S BEEN A
SERIOUS SERIOUS PROBLEM AND IT'S
SORT OF A NEW THING THAT STARTED
HAPPENING. YOU KNOW AROUND THE
TIME AS THE PANDEMIC TO THE COLD
AND WE SAW. THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER PROTESTS. I ASK. A NAY
TWENTY TWENTY. WE ALSO THIRTY
OTHER REFORM APPROACH OF THE
INCREASINGLY BY. THE AND LOCK
GALLAGHER LEADS TO THEIR WITH
ONE DELICIOUS. IN VERY PLACES
AND EVENTUALLY ADD EIGHT VAXXERS
THEIR RANKS. AND WE THOUGHT OF
LOSING AND LITERALLY ARMENIAN
ARMED. WITH NEW PEOPLE WILL HAVE
TO WALK OUT IN PROTEST AND
SOMETIMES JUST IN SERVICE
STORMING FOR EXAMPLE. EIGHT
HOUSES. I AND WHAT'S INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS IS YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
A RELATIVELY RECENT PHENOMENON
TO SEE PARAMILITARY MILITIA
GROUPS. INCLUDING WOMEN WERE
OVERLY RACES WORKING WITH
WEISS'S PROMISES OR REFLECT THE
PROBLEM. ON VARIOUS- POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES THAT'S A VERY VERY.
DIFFERENT THING IN RECENT YEARS.
WE ALSO SAW TERROR WHAT IS HAVE
TO OUT OF BECAUSE YOU'RE
CRUSHING WHITMER WAS ONE.
EXAMPLE WHY TO THE HAPPENING IN
TWENTY FOUR. FIVE GROUP OF THE
MILITIA- FOLKS WILL AFFECT THEIR
WHO IS ALSO ORGANIZED ON
FACEBOOK. THIS DATA FROM APPLE
IS A DEPICTION OF THEACTIVITY
EVOLUTION ARMED GROUPS BETWEEN
MAY AND OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY. YOU KNOW JUST LOOKING AT
THIS YOU CAN GET A SENSE OF HOW
SERIES OF NUMBER OF THE BASS WAS
AND HOW MUCH ACTIVITY THERE WAS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IT IS NOT
SURPRISING THAT SOME OF THE
SITUATIONS GOT QUITE OUT OF HAND
AND BECAME QUITE DANGEROUS. HI
AND THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF A
NUMBER OF EVENTS AND REPORTED
FATALITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
MALICIOUS ACTIVITY BECAME.
BECAME A MUCH MORE VISIBLE
PRESENCE ON PRESENCE ON THE
STREETS AFTER MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY. SO YOU CAN SEE THE BLUE
WHERE HE- KEEPERS WHICH IS A
LARGE PUBLISHING GROUPS. AND
THEIR PROBLEMS. AND FINALLY YOU
CAN SEE HERE DECELERATION OF
PROBABLY THE BEST THAT HAPPENED
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I'D SAY THE MOST
SOME OF THE MOST VIOLENT.
SITUATIONS THAT WE HAD IN LATE
TWENTY TWENTY INVOLVED PROBABLY
INVOLVING THEMSELVES IN PROTEST.
IN WASHINGTON DC IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY. I THE LEADER OF
THE GROUP IS NOW IN JAIL FOR
DESTRUCTION OF PROPERTY LACKS
CHURCHES. IN WASHINGTON DC A
GROUP IS BEING SUED SEVERAL
SETTLING FOR THE ACTIONS THAT
HAPPENED THEN. SO SOME MIGHT END
OF TWENTY TWENTY. THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT TERMS THE STATE
OF HATE AND ENERGIZED ENERGIZED
WHITE SUPREMACIST MOVEMENT
FEATURES NEW TYPES OF OVERTLY.
VIOLENT GROUPS. MANY WARNING
BROWN WHINING CONTINUES TO GROW
ONLINE NAY FED BY REPLACING A
CONSPIRACY THEORY. AND PROTEST
YOU DURING THIS YEAR'S OF
EXTREMIST RELIGIOUS CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS WEISS PROMISES WITH
EVERYONE AND YOU KNOW SOLUTIONS
OF MILEAGE DURING PROTESTS.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN RECENTLY A LOT
OF ADDITIONAL LOGIN AFTER PLOTS.
AND. I HAVE A FEELING AS- I
LIVES. THAT ASKING TO COME MORE
ALL TO LET REAL LITERALLY IN THE
COMING MONTHS. THAT WE'RE GONNA
SEE MORE AND MORE OF THIS OF
STUFF AS WELL AT HAND AND MAKE
LEADING UP. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
HAVE A REALLY. IT WAS ON. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DR WE- WE SEE A
LOT OF THE- WILL. TYPES OF
BEHAVIOR THAT YOU'VE DESCRIBED-
UNFOLDING IN THE NEWSPAPER-
ONLINE- ON OUR DEVICES ON THE
TELEVISION- IT SAID IT'S GOOD TO
HEAR THE CONTEXT THAT YOU
PROVIDED TO US. A FOUR ON ALL OF
THESE ACTIVITIES SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT OUR OUR NEXT
SPEAKER IS SEAMUS HUGHES OF
GEORGE WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY'S
PROGRAM ON EXTREMISM. DEPUTY
DIRECTOR THERE ARE YOU. OUR
WELCOME. THANK YOU I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MEAN I DID NOT
RECEIVE ON AT ASSEMBLY ASA ONE
OUT FLY CALIFORNIA LEGAL WAY ON
THIS ISSUE THAT I'M GETTING
LOCKED UP SOMEONE IN THE FEDERAL
A LITTLE BIT AND THEN NOT BE. A
LITTLE LITTLE LITTLE LITTLE. SO
NOW ON A AB. RECORD LAST EDWARD
WHAT UNIVERSITY. THAT ARE OUT OF
SEVENTY YEARS WHERE WRESTLING.
POLITICAL ORGANIZATION LOOKING
EXTREMISM IN AMERICA AND THEN BE
FAR RIGHT FAR LEFT- YOU NAME IT
IT IS LIKE ANY CITIZEN AMERICA
IN A SENSE OF WHAT YOUR CONTENT.
AND WE GET THAT- EXTREMISM HERE.
SO PRIOR TO I WOULD NEED HELLO
COMMITTEE FOR. YEAR RUNNING OUT.
PROGRAM WHAT ABOUT THOSE ALL.
PACKET UNDER YOU KNOW ON A-
PARTNERS- THE NEXT EVENTS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND- SATTAR SENATE
SECURITY. YOU'RE TALKING ON THE
LEGISLATION AND- QUITE FRANKLY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SAME AND I
VIOLENCE RIGHT IT'S PAST. AND IT
QUITE FRESH. IT IS THE REASON
CHANGE IN THE LAST YEAR YEAH
YEAH FROM SOUTH ACTIVE AT ALL OF
THE STATE TO NEARLY WHEN SEVEN
HUNDRED ABOUT TWO. INCLUDING OUR
INVESTIGATIONS ACTING PART AND
MANY OF WHOM ARE THE FIRST LINE
DEFENSE ON THESE HEADACHES. YEAH
I WORK IN THESE CASES TWO YEARS
AGO ALL THOSE GROUNDLINGS TAXI
AND YOU NOT. BE CASES. USUALLY
WHEN TAKE YOUR CASE HELLO NOW ME
SOME SOLID CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
TRYING TO TAX LESLIE PLAYED A
ACTED DO YOU- QUITE SIMPLY THIS
IS A CHANGE FOR NOT ONLY TO YOU
SEE AMERICA BUT OUR RESPONSE TO
IT WHAT OUT THAT IN A BIT. I
GOING TO BE SLOWLY ACTION MUST
BE TEN WORKS STATE LOCAL
OFFICIALS WERE ANYWAY CAN THE
FIRST LINE. THE IS NOT EASY. WE
ARE THE RECORD DOES AND TERM.
JANUS HELLO FOR AT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. EVER SINCE EARNING AND IN
IS. RACIALLY MOTIVATED VIOLENCE
THE REST ARE MOST LIKELY TO
ATTACK PUBLIC GATHERINGS A LARGE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WHERE IS NOT
LISTED GROUP THAT THAT I COULD
NOT WHAT ARE YOU LAW NFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SETTLEMENT. ELECTED
OFFICIALS ALL RIGHTS AND ARE
AFRAID TO GET ELECTED OFFICIALS
BUT IF THE ELECTION OFFICIALS.
OR ANYONE ELSE BETWEEN. THREE
MONTHS FRACTURE AND ADDS IN
RECENT YEARS. IT'S NOT ALWAYS.
AFTER LIST ALSO. YOUR PERSONAL
WAR IT'S BLUE WAYS IT IS
INVOLUNTARY SELLERS TO QUESTIONS.
MILEAGE IT IS- THIS YEAR'S
HERE'S. PROUD BOYS AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN. IT A BIT
OF A MESS. ALL STOP TRYING TO
CREATE A WAY TO EXPRESS THIS-
RATIONALLY ESCAPE IS GOING TO BE
A CHALLENGE SO MANY RABBITS
HEARING. START TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO WRAP MY HEAD AROUND RIGHT IT
LOOKS A LOT DIFFERENT THAN WHEN
HIGHLY BRIAN I. STARTED THIS
YEAH. I ALSO EXPORTED IT LONNIE
SOCIAL. EIGHT AS NICELY AS YOU
WANT THAT OKAY- OKAY NINE
O'CLOCK. THEY CAN BE THAT A
SALAD BAR- BACK IT IS YEAH YEAH
CALLS THAT HE SHOULD DROWNED
AFTER ALLERGIES GOT A PROBLEM
ALWAYS PROMISES WHAT KIND OF
THAT ARE PROUD BOYS BONTA
DELEGATES WERE ALSO EXPLORATIONS
AND EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN. IT
JUST DOESN'T LOOK. AT THE LET'S
SAY. ANYWAYS WHICH MY SCREEN
BERMAN. IN MANY WAYS GAMERS IS A
KIND OF AN INTERESTING TOUCH
POINT IN A WAY TO LOOK AT
EXTREMISM I DON'T THINK THIS
KNOWLEDGE TO PEOPLE ARE IT IS
INTERESTED IN MON SO THE
PROMISED FREEDOM- WINNIE- THAT
HAVE NOT GAINING ACCESS. TO THE
WEBSITE TO TRACK EVERY FEDERAL
REST AND RELATES TO- YESTERDAY.
THE CAPITAL. I OF THIS MORE REST
HUNDRED FOUR WHICH EARLY OR- YOU
DID A FANTASTIC ON THE POWER.
AND SAW. I REMEMBER IT. WE'RE
SPEAKING OTHER PEOPLE'S GONNA
SEALS WHERE SIXTY SEVEN RIGHT
NOW IT IS LARGEST. FBI EVER DONE.
THREE THOUSAND TESTS PUBLIC
GOING TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND HOURS
ABOUT HIM- KNOW JUST THINGS LIKE
THAT. THE AVERAGE AGE OF A
PERSON ARRESTED IS THIRTY NINE
BUT EXPAND MEETING AT. THE COVER
FORTY FOUR DIFFERENT STATES AND
YOU SEE. CALIFORNIA'S FORTY
HUMAN PEOPLE WHO TO CHARGE THAT
EARLY FOR NEXT JANUARY. SIX
RANKS FIFTH IN THE NATION THAT.
LARGELY ABOUT POPULATIONS. WAIT
ON. I KNOW HAD A MIDDLE OR OR-
THAT EXPERIENCE SEVENTY
INDIVIDUALS IN A NUMBER OF THEM
THAT. IN REAL TIME BUT 80% WHICH
ARE STILL. THEY WERE TAKING SELF.
WHY YOU TALK TO UNIVERSITIES AND
NATURE TO EXPANSION IT IS THE
MANY WAYS- GOOD ALLOCATE A
LARGER THREAT IT'S- THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THERE THAT
ROUTE FROM THE HORN LISTEN
CLOSELY WITH UNIVERSAL CAMELOT.
I STACK ONE NATION WITH THE
RADIOS EVERYBODY OUT BAGS ENERGY
WITH GUNS GOING UP THE FORMATION
THOUGH NUMBERS THERE YOU ALSO
HAD THE IF YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED
TO TALK ABOUT. THE SOCCER. DAD
TAKING SELF CENTERED. THE
PROBABLY SITTING OUTSIDE ITS
ROLE. IT WAS. IT WILL STOCK
EXTREMISM IT ROCKET ARE ALSO A
LOT OF HOST. AND ROCKET IT
FRACTURED NATURE. WHEN DIED THAT
THAT. YOU SEE YOU. A BREAKOUT
SO. OF UNITY FOR THE CHARGED-
ABOUT 50% ARE PART OF AN
ORGANIZED GROUP. SHARES SANDERS
THANK YOU CAN DEBATE WHETHER
ASKED- YOU HAD A NUMBER OF THOSE
STUFF WE'VE ORGANIZED CLUSTERS
SO YOU WANTED TO JOIN EXTREMIST
THROUGH. STILL INSTEAD OF ROGERS
SISTERS AND ROMANCE ALL TRAVEL
TOGETHER. THEN FINALLY AT FORTY
SENATORS AND ASK YOU TO DO WHAT
I NEED TO TALK TO YOU BEFORE.
HE'S FIRED LEADERS- THE
CENTRALIZED NATURE OF. ARTIST
ESTO I AM. I WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
STATE. RESPECT BUT IT GIVES THEM
ANYWAY THE SINGULAR KIND OF BUD
LIGHT YOU BRING TOGETHER WHAT IS
IT ABOUT BUILDING UP FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. I'M GONNA SAY.
ANOTHER THING TO LOOK AT IS ON
THE SEASON FEDERAL SO NOT ONLY
TO CHANGE EXTREMISM AND THE U.
S. CONTEST OF IDEOLOGIES BUT
ALSO WITH YOUR SERVICE OR ACT
ITSELF- THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES THAT ARE HAPPENING. WE
HAD SEEN SINCE THE- EARLY
THURSDAY IT ALONE. THE WHITE
HOUSE AN ASSET YOU MAKE IT HIRES
ALL THINGS THAT I THINK
EXTREMISM YEAH THE WHITE HOUSE
STRATEGY I'M GOING TO TAKE CARE
OF THEM FIRST TIME EVER DONE
THAT WE GET A FIVE YEAR IN A ROW
BY MONEY INTEREST TO GET THAT
TODAY. THEY JOIN BACK UP WITH
THE PRESSURES CALL WHICH BROUGHT
TOGETHER NUMBER DECENCY GRASS
AUTOMATION INTELLIGENCE MAY
CREATE FIRST OF ITS KIND
STATEMENT BUT ADDED THEM LOOK AT
EACH OTHER READ POPULAR IS
PREDATOR ARM HOW MANY SECURITY
THAT IDENTIFIED THE MEDICARE'S
AND ASKING PRIORITY WHICH IS
IMPORTANT FOR POSTED STRONG
BECAUSE IT ALSO MEANS THE GRANT
IS NOW AVAILABLE IN A WAY THAT
HAPPENED BEFORE TO DRESS MASTER
STREAMS OF. INTELLIGENCE
ANALYSIS UNIT EIGHT OUT NOW TO
MEDICARE'S. UNIT LOTS OF
ACCOUNTING ON STREAMS-
PROGRAMMING. ALORS THAT WAS NOT
RIGHT GETTING READY FOR. IF HE
IS HEALTHY INSIDER THREAT REDO
LOOKING AT AND WHO ALL YOU KNOW
EXTREMELY THAT GETTING READY TO
GO TO CASES. YEAH IS MOVING.
YEAH I ALL I DON'T CARE DOESN'T
YEAH CASES ON OKAY THAT IS. HE
WAS TURNING OFF. IF USE ARE THE
COUNTRY ARE INCREASINGLY FOCUSED
ON OUR GOING TO LIFT A TEN GET
ANY HOUSES ON. SO WE'VE SEEN-
ONLY. THE NATURE BRADLEY
EXCHANGE AND OF THE FAR RIGHT-
RIGHT ALSO FAR LEFT INCREASINGLY
SO- WE ALSO CAN'T OUR EYE ON THE
BALL I KNOW THANK. WITH IS-
THERE'S STILL ALEXANDER ALL
STATE WHEN IT TO INTERNET
TERRORISM SO THAT WHEN REYES AS
TALK ABOUT TAX YOU KNOW AND I
HAD- THEY IT GOT. A NUMBER IS A
TIMES OP TO GUYS IS STATE LOCAL
FOLKS WHO WORK AS HE IS TO GET A
SENSE OF WHAT HAPPENED THAT DAY.
THERE'S A STATION IN OFFICE I
SPACES TO LEARN TWENTY FIVE ONE
OF TWENTY PEOPLE ARRESTED FOR.
TERRORISM WHICH DOES NOT HAVE
THE MATHEMATICAL AND
EXPERIMENTAL. THERE'S NO PROFILE
BUT I JUST ROUTE SORRY THERE ARE
VERY LITTLE PROFILE DOMESTIC
EXTREMIST THERE'S NOT A CHECK
BOX THE DAVID HE'S TEN DAYS AND
IT'S GOT. TO BE STRESSED. LAST
NAME EMAIL ID JOINTLY. EARLY
DAYS CONSIDERED AS ARE EQUALLY
THERE. SO WE CAN LOOK AT USE.
AND THIS THING. ARE FINE WITH
THE S. YEAH WE HAVE SEEN AN
UPTICK YEAH- YEAH YEAH TRAVEL-
FOR THAT. ONE I THINK TO MENTION-
IT IS. NOT YET OUT OF GETTING TO
SELL. YEAH TO- SO YOU'RE SIERRA
IN THE SPACE- THE SENATE
GOVERNMENT REACH THE ARGUMENT IN
THEIR EYES THAT- THERE'S A BIG
FOCUS AREAS ARMENIAN CHARGING
SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR PEOPLE
FOR CRIMES. AND NOT CHARGING
OTHER FORMS OF EXTREMISM AT AC.
SO YOU'RE SENATE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS TEAM NUMBER TIME'S
GONNA BASICALLY D. THE HOLY
GRAIL OF RECRUITMENT FUTURE.
WORLD TEAM THE FBI ROLE LONG
FORTUNATELY AND A LITTLE BIT
HEAVIER THAN USED IN THE PAST
WHERE IS HE WILL USUALLY MAKE IT
TO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR THE
C. LEVEL ARE NOW IN RICE.
RESIDENTS STILL HAVE A LITTLE.
AND THAT ALLOCATED TO. WHO ARE
CHARGED WITH THE BY THE ATTACK
ON DNC CALIFORNIA. I THINK IF IT
IS ANY PRIOR BE ABLE TO.
PROBABLY WOULD THE STATE.
FINALLY WILL AT S. A VERY A BIT
OF A- MISSION. HOW WE ADDRESS
THESE TO. SO INTERNATIONAL
TERROR THE TOOLS WE HAVE A TOOL
LOOK AT. CASES DECIDED TO GET
RID OF WE'LL GET A- AS- WHETHER
HE'S AND WHAT'S- WE STATE STATE
LEVEL PARENTS ARE- ARE VERY
QUITE AREA. SIXTEEN ASK ABOUT
JAMES BEING CHARGED WITH-
INCREASING DRUG CHARGES WE'RE
GONNA START IS WHAT'S HOLDING
LETTER SENDS TO THE MOST PART IN
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM CHARGES.
AND ANY INDIVIDUALS NOT BEING
BLACKLISTED BEFORE ANYONE
PRESIDENT FOR TEENS AND YOUNG
ASKING WHAT KIND OF ASSIST. AND
PRISON OFFICIALS NOT GETTING
INTO AND ALTHOUGH THE
PRESIDENTIAL. NOMINEE TO LOOK
FOR WHEN THEY GET OUT. I THINK
YOUR FOR HAVING SIGN IN THE
COURT OR- THANK YOU SO MUCH A
PRE. AND- VERY VERY INTERESTED.
OUR LAST SPEAKER IS NIKKI SANG
FROM THE SIX COALITION AND TO.
ARE YOU THERE. NEARLY. OKAY OKAY
I THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND SPACE- TO SEE TODAY HOW
TO THE INDUSTRY COMPANY- I.
THINK HE'S SAYING I'M A SENIOR
MANAGER POLICY AND ADVOCACY HI
THIS IS A COALITION OF WE ARE
THE NATION'S LARGEST CYNICAL
RATES ADVOCACY AND LEGAL
ORGANIZATION OF. IRELAND'S OUT
FOR MANY PEOPLE HERE IS THE
FIRST TIME YOU'RE HEARING FROM
THE COALITION OR- FROM THE
COMMUNITY AND SO I'LL START WITH
A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND. ON
WHATEVER YOU SEE SHOULDN'T WORK.
OF THE FOUR. LITTLE ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
WORK. I COPY AND I'M JUST YOU
FIGURE OUT ALL THE- YOU ALL
BECAUSE I MY COMPUTER CAN'T BOTH-
THANK YOU QUITE OUT- BUT- IF YOU
GO IN AND- AFTER RIGHT YOU KNOW
IT'S- SO- COALITION- HAS
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND FOR TWENTY
YEARS- FOUNDED EVEN DAYS AFTER
NINE ELEVEN- WHEN THIS IS A
COMMUNITY. SORRY HUGE APPARENTLY
HE CRIMES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES- AND MANY OF YOU WILL
RECALL THAT A FIRST- DEADLY
INTENT BUT A PERSONALLY HATE
CRIME AFTER. NINE ELEVEN. AND HE
WAS SHOT KILLED OUTSIDE OF GAS
YOU SHOULD IN THESE ARE. SO I
TIME EAGLE MEETING CAME TOGETHER
IN JUST THAT NEEDED ORGANIZATION
SHE REACHED. A COMMUNITY AND
ALSO TO FIGHT RESPECTFUL RIGHT
SO. HERE WE ARE TWENTY YEARS
LATER- OUR ORGANIZATIONAL
PRIORITIES ARE YOU CONTACTED ME
FOR ME XIN TREES EVEN INCLUDING
SCHOOLS IMAGINE COMMITTEE POWER
AND EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION.
AND RACISM PROFILE BUT-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUAL WHO
SPECIFICALLY ON- OF HEAT
CREMONINI HERE. SO IT'S AN IMAC
IN THIS FE- NEED ONE RIGHT
RELIGION IN THE- OF YOURS THERE
ARE ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND SIX THE
U. S. WITHOUT ABOUT. HEALTH SO
OF A LARGE ACROSS US OF ALSO
JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT BECAUSE
ENEMIES INDEPENDENT FAITH- I
KNOW THAT THERE IS. SOME.
CONFUSION ABOUT THAT. JUST
CLARIFYING THAT IT IS A TO SEE
ANY RELIGION. UDDI ARE SOME OF
THE ARTICLES OF FAITH I LIKE TO
PUT UP IN A POSITION BECAUSE I
SIX MILLION TEAM. ATTY- THAT'S
ON PURPOSE- BUT THESE ARTICLES
OF FAITH. ESPECIALLY THE TURBAN
AND I'M SURE HERE CAN OFTEN
MAKES THEIR STORY IS FOR HIS
CRIMES AND DISCRIMINATION. IT IS
IMPORTANT YOU'LL RECOGNIZE
ARTICLES OF EIGHT AND HAVE.
SOMEONE STANDING. BUT ALSO
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT RIGHT AS
IN ANY CASE- PEOPLE PRACTICE ON
SATURDAY AND SO. NOT EVERY
PERSON LEADING ALL FIVE OF THE
ARTICLES OF FAITH- NEED TO TURN
IT ON SHORE HERE ARE KIND OF
THAT PARTICULARLY. RECOGNIZABLE
COMPONENTS. I ALSO WANT TO. I
JUST KIND OF SOME KIND.
REGARDING WORSHIPPED. YOU CAN
THIS IS WHERE WE GATHER FOR
PRAYER SERVICE UNTIL ONE- AND
REALLY WANT TO INCLUDE IS A- THE
PAST FEW YEARS HE ALSO.
INCREASES IN. TAX HOUSES OF
WORSHIP ON EVERY FROM. VERY BUT
YOU'RE NOT- MEAN YOU RECALL THAT.
OF THE MASS SHOOTING AT BATTLE
CREEK WISCONSIN. IN TWENTY
TWELVE- AT THE TIME IT WAS. THE
WORST MASS SHOOTING IN U. S.
HISTORY AND- AFTER A FEW DAYS
WHEN THE COALITION- AND MANY
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS- YOU KNOW
STARTING ADVOCACY EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT BRI. DIGITAL
CATEGORIES YOU. AND YOU KNOW AND
SO ON THE TWENTY FIFTH IS THE
FIRST TIME UNITS I ANTI. OF
DEDUCTION. REPORTER SOUL BIT OFF
MINUTES. SIXTIES IN THE U. S. UP
REGION BERMAN SAID HE CRIMES-
YOU KNOW WE GET LOTS OF HE SAYS-
HOMICIDE ASSAULT VANDALISM. IF
YOU'RE LOOKING SPECIFICALLY AT.
TWENTY TWENTY UNIT WAS HE SAID
YEAH HE- WORK THERE WAS AN 82%
INCREASE IN THE INCIDENCE
BETWEEN TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY SO ONCE AGAIN SIX
REMAIN AMONG THE TOP FIVE WITH
THIRTY FEET GROUPS OPERATE IN
THE US AND IT'S ACTUALLY HOMES-
THIS YEAR'S IN THE THIRTY SECOND
HERE. WE JUST NEED TO CONVERSE
AGENCIES REPORTING AND CREWS ARE
STILL SEEING INCREASES THE
NUMBER OF HATE CRIMES- SCHOOL
DAYS ALSO WE ARE READY TO
CHALLENGE FOR SIX YEARS-
EVERYTHING FROM BIAS BASED
BULLYING NAME CALLING TO
PHYSICAL ATTACKS. A DIFFICULT
WORKING DAYS. OR A COUPLE YEARS
AGO. I WHERE WE TALKED ABOUT
SORT OF. YOU ARE ABLE I'M REALLY
INTO IN A AVERAGE OF THE LOTTERY
PRO. ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE YOU
BEEN TRYING USE THE WORD WITH
THE IF YOU THEY ARE NOT REDUCE-
STERN NATION- DOES NOT FROM
EMPLOYEE. IN IOWA PUBLIC IN
PRIVATE COMPANIES. SO I GET A
LITTLE BIT OF MORE NOW US INTO.
A CD CRIME HAVE BOTH OF YOU AND
INSTEAD OF ALSO RAN. I SAID. YOU
HAVE ANY. ON THE- SO. LARGE
LARGE IN TODAY'S INTERNATIONALLY
AND NATIONALLY PLUS MEDIA PER
CHILD CAN FURTHER CULTURAL
COMMUNITIES AT RISK- RIGHT WHEN
SHOULD. AFTER NINE ELEVEN
MUSLIMS ARAB TELEVISION AS THE
COMMUNITIES OF SUN HUGE ARCTIC
ANY CRIMES AND THIS CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN WHENEVER THERE ARE
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY
SO- YOU KNOW AFTER THE PARIS
ATTACKS AFTER DELIBERATE. ATTACK
MARKETAXESS THIS CYNICAL OR AND
OTHER EASY- YOU KNOW SENDS
EMAILS OUT FOR LESSER. I MEAN
VISUAL- THERE ARE IMAGES OF
BROWN MANY GERMANS ALREADY MEDIA
THAT REASONABLE CONCLUSION- BUT
THESE ARE. THE FACTORS INTO THE
PERCEPTION. OF ALL PRODUCTION.
YOU CAN COMMUNITIES. NESTEROV
YOU ASKED ABOUT THE WORLD- THEY
ALSO INFLUENCE HOW WE AND OUR
COMMUNITY HOW TO THE. ABOUT
SAFETY- EXAMPLE WITH EVENTS IN A-
YOU KNOW A LOT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES SELLS FOR BACKLASH-
THE RELEASE THE STERN OF THE
FEAR OF IT OF YOUR THAT EXISTS-
WITHIN WITHIN THESE COMMUNITIES-
WE ALSO DECIDED HE CRIES DURING
THE LAST FEW YEARS ARE
PARTICULARLY THE DAY AFTER
ELECTION. THIS IS THE CASE
REGARDLESS OF POLITICAL PARTY
SO- STUDIOS EXAMPLES OF THAT
WERE PRETTY CRIMES RACIAL OR
ETHNIC BIASES JUMP TO THE DAY
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP WON THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTION- THAT'S
JUST COMING. BACK THE IDEA OF.
EVERLY AT ANOTHER SET HE- THAT
SENATOR SAY YOU EXTREMELY THEM
IT'S EVER NOW OF. BRIGHTON BEACH
AS WELL BUT- THERE IS A 20%
REPORTED CRIMES THE DAY AFTER
PRESIDENT. FIRST ELECTION IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT SO AGAIN WE'RE
SEEING THAT. INCREASING HE
CRIMES OF POLITICAL ACTION
REGARDLESS OF THE POLITICAL
PARTIES- TO TALK ABOUT THE
LARGER INFLUENCE OF DIVISIVE
POLITICAL RHETORIC OF ALL THE
SHARE DISCLAIMER THIS IS A
COLLISION EASE A NONPARTISAN
ORGANIZATION. AND SO ALSO
EXACTLY- AND I'M GONNA COMPANIES
OUT HOSTED EACH SIXTY TRUMPETED
RALLY SORRY 210020% INCREASE IN
A ROW HE COMING TO COME THAT IN
ALSO- WRITER FOR WORKING LOOK AT
THE IDEA THAT OF THE SITE AND HE-
ECONOMIES WHERE TRUMP WON BY
ROOM. THERE'S ANOTHER REASON
PAPER BY AMERICA SHOWS HOW
COLLISIONS PRESIDENT JOHNSON
ACTUALLY LEADING. AND WE'RE
LOOKING OF USES IT THE CITY CAN.
WE ALL CREATING. IN BATTLE
ENERGY EARLY. I'M NOT A HOUSE OF
WORSHIP BY ALSO SMALL- WE'RE NOT
ABLE INCLUDING APPROACH GRAFFITI
OUR MOTTO TO BE- BUT IF YOU TO
KNOW THAT. THIS IS A CALL THAT
IS- RIGHT HE'S OF A BIAS
INCIDENTS AND HATE CRIMES
EXISTED BEFORE GOING TO TRIAL
BECAUSE IT AFTER. GETTING BROKEN
TO KNOW- THAT THE LARGER
DIVISIVE POLITICAL RHETORIC OF
EASY TO BE A CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR- AND THEN- YOU KNOW. IT
SOUNDS IT WILL SAY BY OF WORDS
YOU MATTER RIGHT AS WE WILL SEEM.
I'M MEETING POLITICAL RISK
WRITER THERE'S BEEN ANY IN ANTI
AGING CRIMES- MISERIES EVEN
RENDON CENTER- THAT STRUCK HOW
MATTER SO I'M PRETTY. FOLLOWING
THE OF THE AND ANTI MUSLIM
INCIDENTS ROSE NINETY OVER THE
COURSE JUST LIKE DAYS- WE CAN
PROCESS THAT WOULD PRESIDENT
GEORGE W. BUSH'S. IT IS HONEST
PC. LAUNDRY OF AMERICA MUSLIMS
IN MANY CURRENT DROPPED BY ZERO
MARKETS IN THE FALL DAYS
COMPARED TO THE FOR THE USUALLY
REALLY DO- IF YOU A- OF- HOW
WE'RE GETTING READY TO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON. HEAT IN I YOU KNOW IS
AN EASY A SIX- CAN YOU BIT
DEPRESSING SO I TO ADD- TALKING
ABOUT. THE RESPONSE STATE WHILE
HE DO. SO. WHEN IS THAT WE SEE
THE ARE- THAT THE I. EIGHT ON
ARE. YEAH I WAS ON A REPORTED
THE NOT CALIFORNIA NUMBER KEYS
THAT WOULD OR YOU JUST POLICE
AROUND AND FIRST PLACE- JESUS
COMMITTEE OR CROSS OFFICES TO
INVESTIGATE OR PROBE CHU HE
CRIMES IN HE'S READY TO ON FOR
AGENTS FAILED TO SHARE BEYOND
TIME EARLY- GIVEN I CRIME
REPORTING TODAY. WE OF WHICH YOU
SHOULD BE- GETTING SHOULD RAISE
THERE'S YEAR THE NUMBER OF
PERSON AGENCIES PROVIDING DATA
SAID THE- NINE OF THE DEADLY CAN
EVEN. BACK ON ON OUR- CRIMES
BOTH LEADERS ACTIVE WELL THE
PROBLEM PERSON. OF ANOTHER THAT
WE SEE THAT TO THE SO- MOST ONE
PERSON AGENCY CAT HE CRIMES THE
ON THE MOTOR VEHICLE SO. FOR
EXAMPLE IF I. ACCESS WHEN SICK
THINKING THAT THEY ARE MOSTLY.
THAT OUGHT TO CATCH. AS INTERIM.
SIX SO WE ARE SPECIFICALLY WITH
A COMMUNITY ALSO A THAT MEDICARE
YOU SHOULD THE BIG AND- ONE OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND SOME OF THE
AND WE ARE. TO TRY TO ENSURE A
LOT OF IS CULTURALLY COMPETENT-
ALSO- HOW DEEP UNDERSTANDING OF
OUR OF FAITH OF HAVE A VERY
HAPPY. TO OF THE WORK. THIS IS A
CALL DOT TO J. TO IN OUR ON CITY-
IS ADAM YOU ARE. ALL THE BOTH
RURAL AND SEE LEVEL- WE PRIDE
OUR LEGAL FOR INDIVIDUALS OR
AFFECTED- THAT INCLUDE THE THAT
IT IS SERVICES OR ANY RESOURCE
THAT ARE OUT EARLY WHICH IS
CLASSICAL. MUSIC COMMUNITY THAT
MEANS THEY'RE GOING TO LIVE JOB-
WE ALSO DO A LOT OF WORK A GREAT
OR AS- AT HOUSES WHERE. OF ON
SECURITY IS AND ANY THAT SO
WE'LL SEE HOUSES WHERE SHE- AND
THEN EDUCATION AB OR TO INCREASE
AWARENESS IN THE COMMUNITY- NO
ONE IS AND BY TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHY ACCURATE RECOGNITION OF
THE- IMPORTANCE- THE BOARD THAT
WE DRIVE ADDRESS IDEAS WHEN YOU
SEE IT. TO ADDRESS ITEM ONE
INSTANCE WITH ONE COMMUNITIES
EARLIER TO ADDRESS A IN ALL
CASES ANOTHER BROTHER SILENCES
AND MARGINALIZES GROUPS TO
EXPERIENCE FIVE LIMITED VIOLENCE
AND DISCOURAGES I'M RECORDING
ACTED LIVES COMMUNITY INSTEAD OF
COMMUNITIES- WE ALSO MUST TRACK
AND- WE MUST ACCURATELY TRACKING
CRIMES. IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND
THE PROBLEM ALLOCATE UNNECESSARY
RESOURCES INTO DEVELOPING AN
ACTIVE POLICY SOLUTIONS AND-
PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT
REASONS IS THAT FOR BOTH VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS THAT HE CRIMES
ACCURATE RECOGNIZING. THEM AS A
MATTER OF JUSTICE. BUT I DO NOT
QUICKLY- I JUST WANTED TO YOUR
CYCLE OR YOUR- MY CONTACT INFO
SO HAPPY TO SAY IS THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. THE YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR FOR YOUR- UPPER
FOR YOUR FIVE PAY AND- A FOCUS
AGAIN ALLOW BIT OF THE END OF
ACCURATE- RECOGNITION- ONE OF
YOUR POINTS ABOUT- SECURITY AT-
A SYNAGOGUE SCORED WALLACE-
MAFIA LIKE IT'S SOMETHING WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TAKEN ACTION ON IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE AND WAS IN
FACT A PRIORITY- A BUDGET
PRIORITY OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS OF
WHICH I'M A MEMBER- IN THE-
LEGISLATURE TO- FIND A SECURITY
GRANT PROGRAM- THAT HAS EXISTED
NOW OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF- OF
FLOOD LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS. AND
TOUGH FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
LISTENING AND IF YOU- BELONG TO
A RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATION- THE
SECURITY GRANTS ARE AVAILABLE- I
CAN'T GIVE YOU EXACTLY HOW TO
ACT OF THE- WEBSITE TO ACCESS
THEM BUT- IF YOU'LL CONTACT-
EITHER OF MY OFFICE OR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RACES OFFICE WE CAN GET
THAT INFORMATION TO YOU- THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH MONEY TO GO AROUND
EVERYWHERE ON THESE ARE HIGHLY
SOUGHT AFTER BUT WE DID TRY TO
FIND THEM I THINK WITH THEY WERE
FUNDED AT. A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR SO NOT AN
INCONSEQUENTIAL. AMOUNT OF MONEY.
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES SAID
ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS POINT YEAH.
YES THANK YOU A PROFESSOR LEVIN.
ARE YOU STILL WITH US. THANK YOU
YEAH. I AM HERE. THANKS IN KEY
INSTITUTIONS IS DECLINING I KNOW
THAT RECENTLY R. U. S. SUPREME
COURT MEMBERS OF TALKED ABOUT TO
SOME OF THE MOST TALKED ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THE U. S. SUPREME
COURT NEEDS TO REMAIN THE
INTEGRITY OF THE U. S. SUPREME
COURT NEEDS TO BE SOMETHING THAT
IS UNTOUCHABLE. ANOTHER
INSTITUTION OF COURSE IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND- AS YOU KNOW
SINCE YOU ARE YOU IN THE SAN
BERNARDINO AREA. R. RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SHERIFF. CHAD BIANCO-
SHARED THAT HE- JOIN THE
EXTREMIST GROUP OATH KEEPERS IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN FOUR YEAR
WHILE HE WAS STILL A LIEUTENANT
IN THE DEPARTMENT HE IS NOW THE
SHERIFF FOR RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
CONFIDENCE IN INSTITUTIONS IS
LAW ENFORCEMENT ONE OF THOSE
INSTITUTIONS. THANK YOU FOR AND-
THE BOWL TO ACCOMPLISH MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE STATE. WHAT I
DON'T THINK. WE HAD A SURE OF
WHO WAS A MEMBER OF THE FAMILY
ALL KEEPERS BUT THE USUAL
CHERYL'S IS WELL RICHARD MATSCH
GROUP AND HE- THE HOMELESS
ACTIVIST BACK YOUR- LAW CENTER
IT IS NOT. RIVERSIDE COUNTY SURE
DEPARTMENT PARKWAY LARGE UNITED
STATES ZERO EIGHT RIGHT LAST
YEAR AND WE ALSO SAW ON WORKING.
WE HAVE THE STATE START ARAMBULA
USED IT SHOULD BE FOR I HAVE IS
GOING. ABOUT SHOWN WHO BELONG AT.
THE- KEEPERS. J. WHEN. WANT TO
THESE IN THE- ARE INVOLVED IN
THE CAB GAINS RUSH AND SHE'S.
RASH MEDICAL. YOU SHOULD WE
SHOULD WE GROUP HAVE CHANGED
DOWN WHAT I DIDN'T. ONE OF THE
THINGS WE NEED TO DO IS TO FOCUS
ON SENSE. WHAT MORE BORDER THE
MILITARY IT IS ALSO. THIS WHO
HAS. TO INTELLIGENCE AND
BELIEVERS ALONG PORTION THAT. IS
IT IS NOT THE WORST OF THE PORT
CHIU GROUPS THERE ARE
INSURRECTIONIST GROUPS WILL YOU
JUST CALL. ME WHAT THAT IS SO.
RIGHT ARE WHO HEY WE WILL ON TO
CITIZENS OF A WRITER PRIVATE GUN
OWNERSHIP SO LIKE AND BELIEVE
THAT BLACK DIESEL LEAD ARE RIGHT
ARM RESULT AND EVEN JUST WE ARE
CONCERNED PERSON SAID. THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT ENTITLED TO HAVE
ANY TARGETED GOING ANY TYPE OF
SITUATION AND INDEED HE WAS A
GREEN COURT IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SEARCHES ON THE PROPERTIES SAID
THE- STATE REGULATIONS APPLY.
ARMS WILL ISSUES. HUNDRED USUAL
AND THEY CAN BACK ME UP. I WOULD
I AFFECTING THE- AND THE FIRST
LETTER I LOOK HEAR FROM SHE AND
HIGHLY BECAUSE THEY ARE. WITH
THESE AS WELL. WHAT I DID HAVE A
QUESTION FOR DOCTOR BY RICH. AND
MAYBE- THEY WILL ALSO COMMENT ON
THE ISSUE OF THE INSTITUTION OUR
CONFIDENCE IN OUR INSTITUTIONS
DECLINING BUT- DR BY RICH- YOU
TALKED ABOUT MONITORING WHITE
SUPREMACY AND EXTREMISM. ADD A
COMMENT THAT YOU MADE WAS QUITE
AMERICANS. THE RHETORIC IS A
QUITE AMERICANS ARE FORCIBLY
BEING REPLACED. AND WE HEAR THIS
OFTEN BUT- I'M WONDERING IF
THERE HAVE BEEN INTERVIEWS
WHITE BROTHERS AND SISTERS FEEL
THAT WAY. AND OFTENTIMES THIS IS
THE WAY THEY ARE PORTRAYED AS A
GROUP- HAVE THERE BEEN
INTERVIEWS WITH THOSE WHO ARE
EXTREMISTS ON ONE SIDE AND THOSE
WHO ARE. WHO WHO FEEL
COMFORTABLE IN THEIR OWN SKIN.
AND WHAT HAVE BEEN THE RESULT OF
THOSE INTERVIEWS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- REQUIRED HERE WELL LOOK AT
THE GREAT REPLACEMENT CONSPIRACY
THEORY IS IT IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS THE VIEW HELD BY ALL
WHITE PEOPLE RIGHT IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT IS CRITICALLY
LIVES IN THE MINDS OF PEOPLE WHO
ADDED RADICALIZING TWICE
PERMANENCY SERENA THEM. THAT
SAID WE HAVE FOUND. YOU KNOW
OVER THE LAST YEAR OR SO.
ASSEMBLY MAJOR VIDEO YOU THE
IDEA IS A GREAT REPLACEMENT
WORKING MINIMUM INCLUDING
CONGRESSPEOPLE AND OTHER NEWS
COMMENTATORS IN VIRGINIA WHAT OF
CARLTON ON FOX NEWS. AND SO WHEN
YOU HAVE FIGURES ON USES OF THAT
STOCK AYE AYES PUSHING SOMETHING
THAT IS REALLY JUST A CRAZY
WEISZ'S PURPOSES IDEA IT IS A
PROBLEM AND THIS SERIES IS ALSO
SPREADING THROUGH COMMUNITIES-
DOESN'T EXACTLY ORIGINALLY A
FRESH IDEA. I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT
WE NEED TO APPLY THIS IS
WIDESPREAD AMONG WHITE COMMUNITY
BUT HE CERTAINLY IS WIDESPREAD
AMONG CERTAIN PARTS OF THE BIKE
YOU NEED ADDED TO THE DANGER
WHEN I DID HAVE SOME OF THE
THINGS MOTIVATE IT SHOULD BE
LIKE A TREE OF LIFE OR EL PASO.
LET ME JUST ADD SOMETHING ABOUT
THE PRIDE WAS TALKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT THE THREAT OF
EXTREMISM ON ABORTION INDUSTRY
WAS IN THE MILITARY IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND TO BE
DEALT WITH IMMEDIATELY I'M SO
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS. THAT ALONG
WITH UNIVERSITY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS A PUBLIC POLICY
SCHOOL WHICH PARTY TO RECORD MY
ORAL FOUNDERS. I STARTED A CLASS
ON EXTREMISM LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
WHAT TO DO ABOUT IT IDENTIFYING
IT FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY PROFESSIONALS
SO THEY CAN IDENTIFY THE FINEST
EXTREMISM ON FORCES AND THEN.
TALK ABOUT WHAT YOUR ATTITUDE IS
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING TO THE
INSTITUTIONS THEMSELVES OR ROUTE
THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE
IT IS AN ABSOLUTE DISASTER WE
FIND WAYS TO PROMISES OR YOU
KNOW PARAMILITARY MILITIA TYPES.
ON THE FORCE BECAUSE THEY ARE
NOT HERE TO PATAKI AND
OVERSEER'S INSIDER. THREAT THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I'M YOU
SAID WE ORGANISERS DO THIS- THE
EXTREMISTS IN BOND FOR SMITH.
YEAH I'M I'M AT UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN HEALTH IS IN THEIR
POWER POWER SCHOOL IN APPROACH
TO BY ERROL SOUTHERS CALLED THE
STATE COMMUNITY IS. TO WONDERFUL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IT MISTER
HUGHES IF I MAY. I WAS AT THE-
INTRIGUED BY THE NUMBERS THAT
YOU PROVIDED IN YOUR SLIDE- THAT
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR. OF THOSE
IN THE JANUARY SIX INSURRECTION
WERE CHARGED FEDERALLY AND
SEVENTY EIGHT HAD MILITARY
EXPERIENCE. IS THERE SOMETHING
IN THE MILITARY EXPERIENCE THAT
WOULD LEAD US TO THAT COULD HELP
TO IDENTIFY THOSE WHO WOULD HAVE
THE- AND I KNOW I'M NOT
ARTICULATING MY QUESTION AND A
VERY GOOD WAY BUT- IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE.
IDENTIFIED IN THOSE IN THE
MILITARY THAT COULD. PUSH THEM
TO EXTREMISM AS WE WITNESSED IN
THE JANUARY SIX INSURRECTION.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
GUESS IT'S QUITE IMPORTANT- NOW
IT IS. OBVIOUS ASSEMBLY. IT'S
GENERALLY ON PAR WITH THE
GENERAL POPULATION OF THOSE AT A
MILITARY BACKGROUND THAT US SO
IT'S NOT OUTSIDE WALL WHERE DOES
MY- ROLE IS THE ORGANIZER OF ART
J. UNIVERSAL THE PROUD BOYS CAN
HAVE THAT OUTSIDE WILL LOOK. AT
MILITARY BCKGROUNDS IT IS A
POLITICAL BACK HERE AND WE NEED
TO FOCUS IT ON THE MARKET. ON
THE OLD ACTOR- IN A CRYOGENIC.
DAY ACTIVE IN AN INCREASINGLY
FOCUSED RECRUITMENT ADVERT- FOR
MEMBERS COMING OUT. JOINT
EASTER'S I WAS NOT UNHEARD OF TO
SEE A FLYER- A LITTLE ISSUE BASS
AND THE CASE WAS GONNA COME.
JOIN US IT'S A- LOVE IT AND WE
GOT YEAH. THE LATTER IS USED UP
I THINK HEAR ABOUT IS GONE NOW.
IT'S STILL. AVAILABLE BOARD
THERE THEIR ACADEMIC BACK A DAY
TRAINING. YEAH SOUTHERN STATE
ABOUT A YEAR AGO WITHOUT RELY
PORTION. NO TALKING THREE AND
JENNA ABOUT THE DATA HAD A OF ON
THE BOOKS- THIS IS NOT ACTUALLY
BOTTOM AWHILE NOT. WELL WE-
BETTER- WORLD YOU YOU REALLY
INTERESTED IN YEAH AT AND
THOUGHT AND I WE ARE LIKE RIGHT
THERE IS A THE SENATE EDUCATION-
YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUES OF THE
VERIFICATION I DON'T. THINK IT'S
ALL TO YOUR EDUCATION ALONG WHAT.
OF EASIER NOT JUST KIND OF THIS-
THIS OCULUS ORGANIZATION IN THE
THAT ONE JOINT DON'T YOU KNOW
I'M JUST PART OF THE PAST I
WOULD LOOK AT NOT ONLY- YOU
DECIDED REST OF THOSE THAT ARE
TALKING YOU KNOW RESPECTED-
EXTREMISTS PARTICULARLY ONLINE
AND BASICALLY OVERSEAS. BUT ALSO
ON THE BACK AND THERE'S PLENTY
OF STUFF THAT MEASURE THAT
THERE'S GONNA BE A MANAGED CARE
SYSTEM ARMENIAN DEAL- TO RISING
LEVELS OF- SUPPORT WHAT. ABOUT
HELP OR COUNSELING OR ANY OF
THOSE OTHER THINGS THAT MAY
ALREADY CAUGHT IT OPENING
PROCEDURES TO RECRUIT NEW
DETAILS. ACTIVE AS HAPPY TO
RECRUIT THEM TO TRY TO GIVE THEM
SOME SORT OF ANY ERA OF
RESPECTABILITY BECAUSE THESE
GUYS IT SERVED AND WE'RE DOING-
IS THAT WE NEED IT. TO GET INTO
THE MIDDLE THAT. BEFORE IT
REALLY STARTS. NO THE HE SURE
TRY BUYING HERE TO FURTHER WHAT
MORE ONE TO HAVE THE ABILITY
BACKGROUND SO IT VERY. THE CITY
FLAG AND THE OF BEST WILL ALSO
SEE AND ORDER MAN COULD NOT ONLY
FROM MORE FROM G. BUT APPARENTLY
STERN TYPES OF OFFENDERS IT THEY
ARE WILL. THE DEFENSE OF THE ONE
RESEARCH WILL TO THE WORST LEFT
USED. SO WHEN WELL THERE ARE.
AND WE THERE ARE SHORT HERE TO.
GET MOST WITH THIS KIND OF BACK
THEY CAN SURE. THEMES CHIU WE'RE-
YOUR FRIEND YOUR PROCEDURAL SURE
HAVE FOUNDED IN PRETTY VITAL AT
HOME RIGHT YOU TO DESTROY.
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO MILITARY
BACKGROUND AND COLLEAGUES ALL
MOUNTAINEER WERE VIRGINIA IS ONE
OF IT WOULD THESE KIND OF REAL
TO OFFENDERS JIM THOUGHT OF THE
CAPITAL. HOLDEN DEMOCRAT TO
SHOULD THINK APPEAR HE. OVER AND
OLDER ROUTE AND- IN SOME NOT ALL.
WE'RE REPRESENT OF PEOPLE WITH.
IT DEPENDS ON HOW MUCH YOU
FACTORS AS WELL. SOMETHING THAT
WOULD TO KEEP AN EYE ON OUR END
THE SAYING. I WILL- IN YOUR CAR
TO SAID YOU TALKED TO THE
EMPLOYEE OF CHAU POLITICAL
RHETORIC. HOUSE THEY'RE BUILT A
TIME IN OUR HISTORY WHERE AN-
THE CHARGED POLITICAL RHETORIC
WAS AS BAD AS IT WAS- MAKING. IT
NOT TO POLITICIZE THIS BUT
DURING THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY
DURING THE TRUMP ERA. RUSSIAN ON.
GLAZER EARLIER RIGHT THESE HE
CRIMES DISCRIMINATION- THIS
EXISTED BEFORE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION EXISTS OPERATORS
ALSO- AND IT WAS THE ONE OF THE-
ONE OF THE TIMES WERE I GUESS IN
US HISTORY WE SAW THIS JOTTED
RIGHT AFTER- BUT DOES NOT TO SAY
THAT YOU KNOW THE SECURITIES IN
THE US FOR. OVER A HUNDRED YEARS
IN IS BASICALLY VERY
EXPERIENCING SOME KIND OF
DETERMINATION SINCE YOU GOT HERE
BUT ON. IN THE AFTER NINE
ELEVEN- DEFINITELY LARGE
INCREASES- DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THEN. ALSO
YOU KNOW WHEN THERE'S ANY SORT
OF NATIONAL OR INTERNATIONAL
LARGE SCALE INCIDENT WHERE- IT'S
CREATING ANY TYPE OF KIND OF
FALL COMPLETION OF- MEDIA. AND
THEN. THE POLITICAL WRITER AND-
ALSO SAID IT HAD A FEW. WELL I
TO SAY THAT THE BOTH-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM I MYSELF
HAD THE DISTINCT. PRIVILEGE OF
VISITING THE GOLDEN TEMPLE IN
PUNJAB A FEW YEARS BACK AND-
EXPERIENCING THAT WAS- VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US AND I THINK
THAT AS YOU TALK ABOUT- MAKING
SURE THAT WE PROVIDE THE CORRECT
INFORMATION SO THAT WE DON'T.
MISS IDENTIFIES SOMEONE THAT
WORKED FOR ME WAS- AND THEN
LIGHTNING EXPERIENCE- AND I
WANTED TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU.
NUMBER. YES AND I THANK GOD- THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS EXACTLY CORRECT
AND- IN POINTING OUT THAT WE
LEARNED SO MUCH FROM THAT
EXPERIENCE AND I THINK THAT
LEADS TO- THE L. OR LENDS ITSELF
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF BUILDING
UNDERSTANDING AMONGST PEOPLE
BECAUSE IT'S EGGMAN RENTS A LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING THAT FREQUENTLY
LEADS TO- THE INDIVIDUALS DOWN
THE PATH THAT- IS DESTRUCTIVE IN
THE WAY THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- OF THIS EVENING AND IN
THE SERIES OF HEARINGS- OF
MISTER HUGHES MADE AN
INTERESTING COMMENT- ABOUT THEIR
BE HAVING BEEN A- SEA CHANGE IN
FOCUS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL ANY
IDENTIFIED THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES AND- HOW THEY ARE.
CHANGING TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
AND THREATS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THIS EVENING I'M I'M I'M
WONDERING IF FOR A- WHOEVER
WANTS TO COMMENT- SUMMER ALL OF
YOU- I'M WONDERING IF WE'RE
SEEING THAT THE CHANGE AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- AND IF NOT- DO YOU THINK
WE NEED TO REFOCUS AND THAT WAY
ARE THERE CERTAIN PLACES WHERE
THAT'S MORE IMPORTANT. AND SO
FORTH. YOU CAN JUST JUMP IN. OR
NOT. NO NOBODY ELSE DID. I THINK
SHE- DID IT ACTUALLY JOB IN
SHOWING THE BLOOD LEVEL FACT OR
WHAT HAPPENED WITH RESPECT TO
HIS RUSSIAN WE THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE SURE TO CHARLOTTESVILLE HE'S
KIND OF THE NATIONAL THE VENDORS
THIS IMPLOSION. OF THE GROUP.
RIGHT AND THEN WE SHE- BURKE. OF
I'M SPEAKERS SHE YOUR ROOM AND
I'M JUST GOING TO DO WE WILL
WELL JEFF NORTON THE SACRAMENTO
BEE ON SUNDAY ABOUT HOW THESE
LOCAL KIND OF THE BEST SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING ALL THINGS LIKE.
THAT AND THEN- ACTUALLY GOING
WELL BE SURE DOES SHE NOT HEY
CRIMES RISE EVERY PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION YEAR. WE'RE HOUSING
WERE WE WALK LIFE JUST. A MINUTE
IT ALLOWS ALASKA WE- THEIR A LOT
OF PEOPLE ONLINE AND EXISTING.
FORTY LAST. FOR HEATING IT WAS
SHE REACHED USUALLY EVEN LONG IS
IT DOES JUST AFFECT EXTREMIST.
DISCOURSE ACROSS THE BOARD SO
WHEN YOU LOOK AT FOR INSTANCE WE
SURELY HELP- IS AS HIGH HE SAID.
THIS THIS CHILDREN WE SEEM. ALL
RIGHT I AND THAT KIND OF HISTORY
AND BE SPECIAL ELECTIONS IT WAS
JUST BROUGHT UP WHEN PRESIDENT
OBAMA LOOKED LIKE HE WAS GOING
TO WIN THE NOMINATION AND
ELECTION. WE SURE HATE CRIMES
SPIKE. AS WELL AS- NOTHING
AGAINST SO I GUESS RIGHT USED
WE'RE SEEING HAPPEN MOLD WAYS
ONLINE WE'RE ALSO GRAYSON SHOWED
JUST TO BE BULLYING LIKE THAT
AND WOULD CONCERNED ABOUT AND
WHAT YOU WHAT YOU WANT ASSEMBLY.
WITH THIS COMMITTEE OLD HAS BEEN
MODELLING EXACTLY THE WAY WE
NEED TO HAVE DISCOURSE BECAUSE
WHAT WE'RE SEEING OUT I JUST GOT
DONE WITH. THE U. N. MEETING
EARLIER TODAY WE'RE SEEING THIS
PROBLEM WORLDWIDE THIS IS
POPULISM IS AFFECTED LOCAL
MUTUAL WELL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE DISTRACTORS RIGHT I THINK
WE'RE WISHING POWELL RAF AND
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES AND
DIFFERENT MANIFESTATIONS WHICH
TRIGGERED A PERFECTLY WILL BE
VIOLENT PROTESTS THEN THEY'LL
BECOME QUIET. IF YOU THINK WE
SHOULD IN THE MAP ON THE SIDE OF
THINGS LIKE THAT SO OFTEN
FORTUNATELY WELL WE'RE SEEING A
VERY AS SHE SAID ROCHER AND
CHENEY WAS LANDSCAPING WILL
IMPORT AND WHAT HAPPENED IS THE
DISCO MEDICAL TYPE OF HOT BUTTON
PUSHING HOW TO REVERSE THE FAST
ONLINE AND ON THE. STREET SHARES
THE- IT WOULD JUST ADD ONE ONE
THING I THINK RIDING THE. YOU
CAN GET ANY KIND AND I GOT THE-
YOU KNOW I NEED TO BE BOUND.
LOOKING AT THE GENERAL US TWENTY
YEARS. IT APPEARS THEY WERE NOT
ALLOWED EIGHT- THE EXTENT WHERE-
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING ON AND
OFF. WITH IT COULD OFTEN AND WE
YEAH AND SO MUCH ANYMORE AND
WE'RE FINDING A EXIST ONLINE
WHERE. YOU THAT WOULD BE. OUT OF
THE MAINSTREAM JOURNALISTS.
FOLLOWERS ON TWITTER OR FACEBOOK
pGROUPS AND THINGS LIKE THAT YOU
KNOW I THINK YOU HAVE THAT OF
NORMALIZATION OF THE ARE IS
BASICALLY PLACE- AND- REGULAR
PATTERNS. TAX WHETHER EVEN A
SMALL SCALE ATTACKS IN TAXES IN
OHIO MINNEAPOLIS- WE WILL WORK
IT KIND. OF REMINDS ME A LOT.
WHERE WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
OTHER ADDRESS ARE YOU KNOW THE
CITY THE- AND I'M NOT SURE
WILLING TO STEP THAT AS EITHER
ONE OF THOSE. TRUE THANK YOU A
WEIRD. BERNIE THE FUNDING NOTE
IS- PLUS THREAT IT'S HARDER IF I
ANY IT IS EASY TO REFERENCE
AROUND. IF THEY HAVE SOME WE CAN
KIND OF THAT THAT'LL IN. YOU CAN
HOLD YOUR SISTER. TOWARD IT YOU
TRAINING HARDER TO DO IT NEW
YORK HELLO THIS REPORT. IT IS
HARD TO DO. YOU'RE TALKING A NEW
STYLE YEAH. OR HONEST I YEAH.
WHICH KIND OF CELEBRATION IS ONE
DAY WHAT KIND OF NOT A IN AND
DAY UNITED. IT IS KIND OF HARD.
OF I GUESS. IT IS HARD AROUND
AROUND BOTH THE PUBLIC AND I
LIKE TO FISH SAY WE GET A TAX
THIS IF WE CAN'T FIND. IT SAYS
OTHER THAN WE KNOW THAT RIGHT.
SO WE NEED TO WRAP AROUND A CALL
NOT ONLY FOR ACADEMICS ACTIVISTS
BUT ALSO THE PUBLIC AT LARGE TO
SAY YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT.
ACCEPTABLE NOR RIGHT NOW. YOU
THANK YOU VERY I GOING TO- LET
EVERYONE AND- WE WANT TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT NO WHAT THE
TELEPHONE NUMBERS TO CALL IN ON
IN THE ACCESS CODE SO. GET A
PIECE OF PAPER AND- WRITING
GONNA IMPLEMENT READY THE PHONE
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
ALL REPEAT THAT AT EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
THAT YOU'LL NEED. IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE. ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO. WHILE WE'RE- WAITING
TO SEE IF THERE'S A QUEUE- THOSE
ANSWERS WERE- EXTREMELY
INTERESTING AND ALARMING IN SOME
WAYS- BUT I THINK- UNFORTUNATELY
MY QUESTION AND THEY WERE
EXCELLENT ANSWERS IT ACTUALLY
VERY ILLUMINATING. BUT MY
QUESTION HAD TO DO WITH- THE
REFOCUS OF- FEDERAL AGENCIES ON
THIS WHOLE- AREA OF BUT HATE
CRIMES IN SPEECH  ACTIVITIES
AND SO FORTH AND I'M WONDERING.
WHETHER WE'RE SEEING THAT
REFOCUS IN OUR STATE AGENCIES
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND SO FORTH-
OR- DO WE NEED HAVE MORE WORK
THAT WE NEED TO DO THEIR AS
STATE POLICY MAKERS YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN AND- KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT. I JUST VERY QUICKLY ADDED
I GOT A LOT OF WILD WEST- I IT
IS CLEARLY A FEDERAL HATE CRIME%
DATABASES ADEQUATE- AND SO FAR
THAT WE HAVE LOST UP- THIS THIS
IS A LITTLE ADVERSE ON ADDING
HER SO AS TO NOT ONLY FOR THAT A
LITTLE BIT ALSO GET ON
REPORTING- INTERNALLY- THINGS
LIKE WORKING NIGHT- CALIFORNIA
DOING IT IS IMPORTANT. BUT THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER STATE LEVEL
FOR THOSE THAT ARE OPEN AND
HONEST. YES AND NOW- SOME STATES
HAVE ANIMATED KIND OF THE THIS
IS THE RESULT. OF IT IS. THAT
WE'RE GONNA. AND THAT'S HOW
EVOLVED INTO. STATURE OF AWAY
WHAT IS THE FOCUS OF- SO I.
FIGURED THE ROLE. OF THAT WE-
RIGHT YOU TALK TO ANY LOCAL
CENTER. AROUND THE- THEY SAW
THIS WHOLE SYSTEM WE CAN READ.
AND NOBODY. EIGHT YEARS AND WHAT
ARE YOU TALKING IT RATHER HEAD
AROUND OF THAT HAPPENING AND AS
OF OLD ALL. WHERE FEDERAL TRADE
MAJOR A LITTLE NOW WITH TO MAKE
STATE LOCALS TO THE FEDERAL TO
SAY LISTEN YOU GOTTA. I'M SEEING
HAPPENING ON THE STREET MIGHT BE.
SEEN THAT THAT UNSEATED FOR ITS
TIME EIGHT TO THIS- AND I THINK
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WAS KIND
OF INFORMATION SHARING
AGREEMENTS. NOT THAT STATUS.
FEDERAL AND AWARENESS MORE
COMPREHENSIVE IN NATURE I DON'T
EVEN MIND THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BE WRAPPED WITH PRIVACY CIVIL
LIBERTIES. AND ALL THIS. OR YOU
CAN STREAM. IT WAS JUST ACROSS
LEGAL RIGHT. MANY ASKED. DO YOU
SEE ISSUES- AND I DON'T. I
DON'T- ANY OPPOSITION A HOW DO
YOU DEAL WITH IT BUT I THINK THE
PORT VISA. THEIR DEDICATED- YEAH
I AGREE YES AND NO AS WELL.
ORANGE COUNTY IS THAT- BUT EVEN
IF WE DO SEIZE OFFERS- OF WOMEN
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE OR EVEN
THE CITY COUNCIL- ALWAYS
TRANSLATE TO THE DEALERS
VISITORS COMING. FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO- AMPLE. MIGHT
BE- I THINK PEOPLE ARE JUST
RESOURCE ACROSS THE US ARE ONE
OF THEM- HAVEN'T REPORTED ANY
INTENSITY CRIMES US IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THAT. THE ADVERSITY THAT
A CATEGORY- HE USUALLY KNOW THAT
NOT- UNIVERSITY HAS A VERY LARGE
A COMMUNITY AND- YOU KNOW YOU
PROPOSED TO ONE PERSON AGENCIES
TO ADDRESS. OF THE TRACKING
ISSUE- THE I THINK YOU'RE
TALKING AND ALSO TRAINING ISSUE
SOMETIMES A RESPONSE THAT WE GET
IS JUST YOU KNOW THIS IS A
DIVERSE AREA AND MY OUR- LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOESN'T NEED
INFORMATION OR WE ARE YOU KNOW-
BUT THE PROBLEM IS IF YOU
ALREADY KNOW IT AND- WHY AREN'T
YOU ACCURATELY CATEGORISING. SO
I EAT YES DEFINITELY COMPLICATED
ISSUE AND I THINK ONE THAT WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS FROM- YOU KNOW
COMMUNITIES. SURE IF PEOPLE ARE
AWARE OF WHERE AND HOW TO REPORT
HATE CRIMES OF ALL POLICY CAN
REMEDIATE MEASURE THAT. THE
STATE LIES OF OUR AND
INCLUSIVITY CANDY RIGHT. ACROSS
YOUR THAT DON'T HE REMINISCED
LESION- SO- NOT- AND THEN ALSO
THE- ARE YOU SEE A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH THEIR- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OUR DO WE HAVE ANY ONE WAY
IN THE TO GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT.
LADIES GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
RECOMMENDED AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND
WE'RE ASKING GOD THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE GIVING PUBLIC COMMENT TO
PLEASE. HOLD THEM TO NINETY
SECONDS. OUR FIRST PUBLIC
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE IT
COULD BE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
NINETEEN AM I IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY- STATE OF HATE
MANY ACCORDING TO GERMAN RIGHT
PLEASE. HOLD HELLO COLLEGE
THROUGH- IN RECENT WEEKS- IS
DELIVERED EVAN LOW SCHERING'S.
YEAH. PLEASE STAND. ANYTHING I
THINK IT'S A LITTLE STRANGE THAT
WE ARE BEING LIMITED OUT OF THE
PUBLIC TO NINETY SECONDS WHEN WE
JUST LISTEN TO YOU AND YOUR
EXPERT FOR OVER NINETY MINUTES
BECAUSE GOVERNMENT ABOUT PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT BUREAUCRAT. AND
IF YOU'RE TAKING KALRA. ALL YOU
KNOW TO CLOSE TO LIKE WILL
REMAIN. WHEN HE GOING TO PUT IN
THE- BACK WHEN HE COMMITTEE OR
CREATE A COURT HEARING WITH-
CAPITAL. WHEN HE DIDN'T HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT. I'M NOT SURE
WHAT TO DO WITH MY LIFE- YOU
KNOW FORTY FIVE SECONDS. I THINK
IT'S REALLY A LITTLE BIT YOU ARE
WANTING PEOPLE AND WE WANT TO
MAKE THEIR OWN MEDICAL DECISIONS
IN WITH TERRORISTS I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT THERE
WERE TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE PEOPLE
A LOT OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CAPITOL YESTERDAY. FOR THE FIRST
TIME THAT THIS HAPPENED WE HAD
I'M VERY PEOPLE GATHERING IN A
LOT OF THOUSANDS OF THE PEOPLE
WHO BELIEVE THAT IT IS NOT THE
pGOVERNMENT'S RIGHT TO THE FAR
RIGHT. WHAT IT IS INJECTED INTO
THEIR BODIES. PARIS THEN THE
PACKAGE TO BE WELL A FEW WITH
PEOPLE WHO FOR. IT REALLY.
ANALOG TO ME AND MEETING ON
MEASURE THREE OF THE SUCH A
ISSUE IN THIS. HOW FOR ACTUALLY
THE HOLDING OF SESSION THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT
THE THING- HOLDING THAT TO DEAL
WITH MEDICAL FREEDOM AND HUMAN
RIGHT WHAT DO YOU DO YOU ARE
TRYING. TO SUPPORT. THE EURO.
RIGHT YOUR IS THE COULD YOU WRAP
UP. IT NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM LINE
IT'S TWENTY LEGAL AT. DIGITAL
CHECKING HEARING. WE CAN WELCOME
PERFECT THANK YOU- HE WAS
EMBARRASSED IN UNITED A
COORDINATOR ARE YOU NATIONAL
COMMUNITY AMERICA WESTERN REGION
AND I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS I WOULD
USE IT WORKERS STILL LEANING UP
THROUGHOUT GENERATIONS TO THE
POINT FOR A WORD BETWEEN ARMENIA
HEATING ARMENIAN AZERBAIJANI
ARE. CONCERNING INCREASE IN
CRIMES ACROSS THE WORLD
MOTORIZATION OF YOUR HEATERS NOW
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S THOUGH HE
CRASHED INCLUDED EARNING DOWN
SEEING GREGORY ARMENIAN ALSO
CHURCH IS CURRENTLY UNDER
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION GUNSHOTS
FIRED AT THE STATE IN THE
ARMENIAN SCHOOL TO THE PRIMARY
SCHOOL IN SAN FRANCISCO AS WELL
AS VADALISM WIKISPECIES
INTERROGATIONS- GLIDED ACROSS
THE PRIMARY SCHOOL GATHERS- AND
SEPARATELY THERE WAS A NEW
PATIENT OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
MEMORIAL DAVIS AND NOT LOOKING
AT LOS ANGELES JUST ILLUSTRATED
IS NOT ONLY A STATE WIDE
NATIONWIDE WORLDWIDE ISSUE BUT
LOOKING AT OF LOS ANGELES WE SAW
ARMENIAN PROTESTERS BEING BEING.
WITH ONE PURCHASING THE VIOLENCE
AGAINST ARGUES IT EARLY IN THE
WAR AND MORE PRIMARY AND
SECONDARY SCHOOL WOULD ANALYZE
WITH EACH DH INTERNATIONAL
GUIDELINES YET AGAIN SO AT THE
END OF THE CENTER OF THESE
INCIDENTS WE FIND THAT PATCHES
ORGANIZATION LIKE THAT REALLY
WILL ALTER NATIONALISTS ARAMBULA
MOTOR THE EDITOR EDUCATIONIST-
AND OTHERS HAD INCITED VIOLENCE
GENEROSITY HAS ARMENIANS BOTH
ONLINE AND IN PERSON NOW TO
ADDRESS THIS THE ANTI WESTERN
REGION LOST ITS DUTIES FOR THAT
PROGRAM JESSICA QUANTIFY EXACTLY
HOW THAT THE INCIDENTS ARE. AND
WE FOUND THAT ROUGHLY 60% OF
RESPONDENTS REPORTED CONCERNING
INCREASES IN OUR INABILITY
INCIDENTS- MORE THAN 55%
REPORTED EIGHT ONE MANY
PUBLICATIONS ALTOGETHER BECAUSE
THEY FEAR FOR THEIR SAFETY AND
REALLY WE FEEL AN ADDITIONAL
DRESSES THE FF CARE ACT. PLEASE
WRAP UP YOUR COMMENTS. WELL
YOU'RE LYING EIGHTEEN. YOUR
ORDER SHARE WITH NATIONAL. ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION. PADA YEAH YOUR IT
AT A VERY TO AND 573% IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY HELLO OUR
ORGANIZATION IN A BILL THIS
YEAR- OVERNIGHT THE NATIONAL.
ACROSS INDUSTRIES IN ORDER TO
CALIFORNIA WE HAD MORE THAN.
WHAT IT IS OKAY. IT IS NOT WHEN
YOU'RE CITY. LISTEN CALIFORNIA
PI MISTER CAR GRABBING- ONE
HUNDRED BECAUSE OF THE MODOC.
HELLO A FIVE. THE NEW UNTO US TO
BUDGET OF THESE COMPANIES WILL
BE DISPOSED NORMALLY ARE
AWARENESS AGAINST ANTI. INDIAN
CURRIES- RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY.
AND ACTUALLY HEAR FROM WIND.
THREE BOB CORNING AND PART OF
THE AMERICAN JEWISH COMMITTEE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK ON THE CEDAR TODAY AND
IN ORDER TO HOPE THAT AS YOU
OKAY IN THE FUTURE OF IT IS ALSO
THE FOCUSING ON. THE ONLINE HEY.
BERMAN ASIAN THAT IT IS JUST-
AND WHAT THAT I WAS HOPING THAT
MAYBE- COMMISSION- THAT SHE'D BE
ABLE TO ESTABLISHING KERR WILL
BRING TOGETHER THE TECH
COMMUNITY BUT A SOCIAL MEDIA
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE GROWN.
MORE AND SEVEN WORK WITH THEM TO
DO A MUCH BETTER JOB OF
CONTROLLING AND MINIMIZING HEY
ONLINE BUT IT WILL COME ALL THE
STICKERS IT IS CONTINUING TO BE
AS A CLEAN STORE ABOUT THAT. WE
HAVE OUT IN THE- A THE LOCAL.
MARCH DEVELOPING WORK MILIEU OUT
THERE FOCUSED ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS I
WILL BE OUT THE- WE HAVE HAD UP
PRIOR HEARINGS WHERE WE HAVE-
DELVED INTO OFF ON LIVE EIGHT
TO- BUT THERE CERTAINLY IS A LOT
TO DO THERE AND I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THE COMMISSION- SHOULD
FOCUS SOME SIGNIFICANT ENERGY ON
THAT ISSUE. NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM LINE TWENTY TWO. HELLO-
MUKUND BENJAMIN- AND MONOCLE
WE'LL CALL IN- COLIN ARE
REGARDING OUR LIMITED EDITION-
GET A CALL BACK IN HISTORY-
HELPING- WHICH- WILL DEFINITELY
HAVE A THE FREEDOM AND. AND READ
FREE ACCES ARE. NO CRACKED- KNOW.
I'M ARTICLE DETAINED- OF-
DEPARTMENT. AFFAIRS DID YOU KNOW
THAT WOULD BE ARTICLE OF A
UNITED NATION AND IT REALLY
AREN'T NONCHALANTLY BUDGET IT'S
LARGER ARTICLE. RECOGNITION THEY
ARE COUNTING AND TAKING HER.
NOMINATION FOR THE JACQUI.
MEDICAL CENTER EIGHT. OKAY
PARTITION IS ARE THE LEGISLATORS
TO. USUAL AUTOMATED FROM PERSON
TO THE IT WILL ON EAGLE THEY ON
THE- END THE GENERAL SHE OR HE.
R. AND G. ARE CAUSING DON'T.
YEAH MY YEARS YOU ABOUT- HE
CLEARLY FROM SOUTHERN ARE YOU
KNOW TO CHANGE OF THE BAY ON
HISTORY- HOW A LOT OF THE ARE
DONE AND WAS TESTIFYING THEY ON
PEOPLE AND HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT
OTHER PEOPLE BASED ON A
PARTICULAR DAY. OR THEIR ANY NAY
YOUR ATTY AND WHAT AND BEING-
ALL THE LEARNERS YEAH- A LOT OF
THINGS THAT FORM. BUT I DO WANT
TO- CREATE LITTLE ONES TWO YEARS
THIS BOOK ABOUT- VISION ON BOARD
WITH ANY. TASK ARAMBULA PLACE.
YEAH HE WILL HAVE THE RIGHT.
LEADING WILL ALSO- THANK. LOS
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU. AND EXCELLING FROM ONE WELL.
GOOD MORNING THE CAME AGAIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA EIGHT BILLION
CALIFORNIA ACTION- THANK YOU TO
THE CEREMONY THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE EVENING- ENABLE IT TO THE
SPEAKERS SPECIFICALLY COULD HE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE NEED FOR A
STATE LEGISLATION HOWEVER SOME
ARGUE WITH STATES THAT DON'T
HAPPENING CRIME LEGISLATION
REQUIRING LEGISLATION. AS WELL
AS TEACHING OF EARLIER IT WAS
FOR YOUR REMARKS ABOUT THEIR
CONCERNS LITTLE PRIVACY AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES MY QUESTION FOR
YOU IS- ETERNITY I HAVE
SUGGESTIONS OR RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATION TO PREVENT
ANY UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
HARM FOR EXAMPLE THE WINNING
RESULTS- OF INCREASED PROFILING
OR SURVEILLANCE OR HARASSMENT-
FROM THE STATE OR LOCAL ENTITIES
PARTICULARLY TO ALREADY
MARGINALIZED GROUPS AS A RESULT
OF ISLAMOPHOBIA HOMOPHOBIA. AND
RACISM TO CANADA. I GOD SAID
THIS IS YOUR- TO PROVIDE TO THE
SELECTED- I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
QUESTION WAS THAT YOU WERE
ASKING BUT I THINK WE'RE
PROBABLY ALL IN AGREEMENT- THAT
WE NEED TO FOCUS- AS THE- MUCH
TIME AS POSSIBLE IN THE-
HEARINGS GOING FORWARD. AS WE
HAVE IN THE PAST ON- I HATED ALL
OF ITS FORMS. AND DEATH OF A
WITH THE COMMISSION- THE NEWLY
FORMED COMMISSION HASN'T TENDED
TO DO. NEXT WELL SORRY ABOUT
THAT BUT I THINK I THINK THAT- I
WON'T LEAVE ROOM TO ASK BUT I
CAN GET IN BUT I DIDN'T GET IT
WHAT I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THE
COMMITTEE VOTED ON ASIA. HOW CAN
WE MAKE SURE THAT FUTURE
LEGISLATION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T RESULT IN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AS WELL
WORKING TO HAVE CONTACTED THE HE
CRIME. FOR EXAMPLE NOT RESULTING
IN INCREASED PROFILING RACIAL
PROFILING AND SURVEILLANCE AND
HARASSMENT- OF ALREADY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES FOR
EXAMPLE HALF FULL TASK FORCES
ALLEN- YOU KNOW EITHER URBAN
COMMUNITY. COMMUNITY I THANK YOU.
SO I THINK ALL OF. ALL
LEGISLATORS ARE WELL OF TO TRY
AND- AVOID UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THE- I KNOW A
MYSTERIOUS AND I BOTH WHEN WE'RE
EVALUATING. AND CARRYING
LEGISLATION WE TRIED TO DO THAT
WE DON'T ALWAYS- ANTICIPATE WITH
SOME OF THOSE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ARE- AND IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES IT'S NOT UNCOMMON.
TO DO WHAT WE CALL CLEAN UP
LEGISLATION TO- TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION AFFECT SOME OF THE- I
THINK THAT- LANGUAGE THAT MIGHT
BE AND- IN- IN A BILL. THAT
OCCURRED BECAUSE AS YOU SAY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SO- GLAD
THAT YOU RAISE THAT ISSUE
SOMETHING THAT WE DO THINK ABOUT
AND WILL CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT
THE FUTURE. THE WAY I HAVE THE
NEXT BIG REPLACE. NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM LINE TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
EVENING- TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BLOOM AND RANTS MY NAME'S
RICHARD HIRSCH OUT I AM DECIDING
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR OF AMERICAN
JEWISH COMMITTEE WE ARE GRATEFUL
TO THE COMMUNITY AND TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PASSING THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT MEASURE ADDED WE
HEARD FROM PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AS
WE'VE HEARD. WITH RESPECT TO
THE- JUST GUT WRENCHING
TESTIMONY AND TESTIMONIALS ABOUT
THE 80 DEGREES OF HATE AND
PREJUDICE AND INFIDELITY THAT WE
HAVE EXPERIENCE IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY DURING THE PADDACK
ONE THING IS CLEAR TO LOS.
ANGELES CA THAT IS THAT HATE IS
INDIVISIBLE AND WE MUST STAND
SQUARELY SHOULDER TO SHOULDER
TOGETHER AND UNIFIED IN THIS
SHARED STRUGGLE TO- JUST SEE THE
BETTER ANGELS OF OUR STATE AND
PROVIDE COMFORT AND A SENSE OF-
PEACE OF MIND SECURITY NOT ALL
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE. WE SUPPORT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY THE CREATION OF A
NEW COMMISSION BECAUSE
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS IS ABOUT ALLY
SHIP THIS IS ABOUT UNDERSTANDING
WHAT CAUSES EACH OF US A. N. AND
WHAT BRINGS US COMFORT THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY HAD EXPERIENCE-
ALARMING LEVELS OF THAT ENZYME
INTO THEM OVER THE LAST YEAR
PARTICULARLY DURING THE MAY
CONFLICT IN THE MIDDLE EAST
BETWEEN HAMAS. AND ISRAEL AND
THAT PLAYED OUT AN UGLY BOB
CREWE AND STOCKAGE DAYS ON THE
STREETS OF LOS ANGELES AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE TO BE BETTER THAN THIS WE
WILL BE BETTER THAT AS WITH THE
COMMISSION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO LEADING ALL OF OUR SUPPORT
SEEING THAT IMPORTANT WORK.
CARRY FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY. AN EXPLORER FROM LINE
TWENTY. HAVE YOU THE FINE AGREE
ON HOW OTHER VIOLENCE IF RELATED
GREAT THEN BECAUSE- AND
EXPECTATIONS ABOUT MASCULINITY
WHAT PERCENT OF THE PROSPECTS
WERE BANISHED OR MASCULINE. WHAT
PRESENT PRACTICES COMPASSION
MEDITATION OR MOB MENTALITY WHAT
PERCENT LEARNED SENATE- OR
COMPASSION MEDITATION IN PUBLIC
SCHOOL. WHAT PERCENT OF THEM
PAID RESTITUTION TO THEIR TARGET.
HOW MANY OF THE SUSPECT ACTUALLY
LOST THEIR JOB HOME ATTORNEY OR
SOCIAL SERVICES VETERANS. HAVE
THEY EVEN RESTITUTED FOR THOSE
LOSSES THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM LINE
TWENTY SIX. ALL RIGHT- UNDER OF
THIS EARLIER AND- THE- CORRECT.
THANK YOU TO GROUPS OUT THERE
THAT IS NOT A DEBATE ON VERY
FAST FOOD IS KNOWN AS THE L. M.
AND KEEP UP. THIS IS A VERY-
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE CORRECT INFORMATION
THE AGES THERE AND THE INTERNET
AT. ONE FIFTEEN NO ACTUALLY
STARTED FIRES THAT. AND- YOU
KNOW LOOKING INTO PART OF THE
REPAIRS. THAT ALONG BUT IT'LL I
DON'T KNOW DESIRE. WHICH IS VERY
WALKING- THANK YOUNG IRISH NEED
NOT APPLY. BUT YOU KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON AND WE LOOK AT THE
OVERALL PICTURE OF HOW TO BE AN
AMERICAN AND YET. THANK YOU.
NEXT BIGGER PLACE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL. A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE HOSTED AN EVENT
CALLED- THAT WE ENTITLED TO A
STATE OF HATE STATE OF HOPE.
WHERE WE WERE PROVIDED. WITH
SUCH TROUBLING STATISTICS AROUND
HATE CRIMES THAT WERE MITIGATED
BY SOCIAL SERVICE SURVEY. DATA
THAT SHOWED INTERGROUP RACE
RELATIONS WERE ACTUALLY
IMPROVING DESPITE THE UPWARD
TREND AND HATE CRIME AND- THIS
MAY NO LONGER BE THE CASE.
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT THESE FACTS
AND FIGURES CAN BE OVERWHELMING
AND DISCOURAGING AND I'M SURE
THAT MANY OF YOU OUT THERE
TUNING IN AT HOME. SHARE SIMILAR
CONCERNS. SO WHAT DO WE DO HOW
DO WE DIFFUSE THAT'S GROWING
LEVEL OF HATE HOW DO WE BALANCE
FREE SPEECH WITH INCENDIARY HATE
SPEECH ON SOCIAL MEDIA HOW DO WE
ENSURE. THE MOST VULNERABLE
AMONG US FEEL SAFE. HEARD AND
PROTECTED AS LEADERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES HOW DO WE PREPARE
HANDLE POTENTIAL CONFRONTATIONS.
AND RESPOND TO ACTS OF TARGETED
VIOLENCE AS WE CONTINUE TO HOLD
HEARING SUCH AS THIS I REMAIN
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL BE GUIDED
TOWARDS FINDING ANSWERS TO THESE
QUESTIONS. AND MORE ARE WHICH
AND MORE WHICH IS TANTAMOUNT TO
OUR ABILITY TO CHALLENGE HATE
AND VIOLENCE HAS GONE UP SO AS
WE CONCLUDE OUR HEARING TODAY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE TO HAVE ANY
CLOSING REMARKS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE. I THINK TO REPEAT
SOMETHING YOU'D SERVICE SAID
EARLIER AND THAT'S THAT WE
CANNOT NORMALIZE HATE AND
EXTREMISM. AND I THINK ONE OF
THE COMMENTS FROM SOMEBODY WHO
CALLED IN WAS THAT WE DIDN'T WE
NEED TO STAND UNIFIED. AND I
THINK THAT WE CAN AND WE WILL.
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER IGNORANCE
AND LACK OF UNDERSTANDING IS
OFTEN AT THE ROOT OF THIS HATRED
THIS EXTREMISM. AND WE HAVE TO
FIGHT AGAINST IT. SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HOSTING THIS HEARING
ONCE AGAIN I AM SO GLAD THAT I'M
A PART OF YOUR COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND- AS WE CONCLUDE
LET ME THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO HAD TO DEPART A LITTLE
BIT EARLY. FOR JOINING US HERE
THIS EVENING AND OFFERING. YOUR
INSIGHT AND THE- A AND OTHER
COMMENTS. A VERY BIG THANK YOU
TO OUR FANTASTIC PANELIST BRIAN
LEVIN HEIDI BERWICK. FAMOUS
HUGHES AND THE KEY THING. WE
COULD NOT HOLD THESE HEARINGS
WITHOUT YOUR SKILL AND EXPERTISE
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
STAFF WHO ARE HERE- WHO HELPED
US TO. MAKE THIS PROGRAM A
REALITY TODAY IN PARTICULAR
MELISSA KOFFLER. WHO HAS WORKED
FOR SEVERAL WEEKS TO- PULL THIS
TOGETHER AND- AS WELL OTHER
MEMBERS OF MY DISTRICT STAFF.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO ATTENDED THE
HEARING- AND- WATCH US ONLINE-
THIS IS- AT A VERY VERY. I IT'S
VERY VERY IMPORTANT THAT. WE NOT
DO THIS IN A VACUUM THAT TO.
MANY PEOPLE BE LISTENING AND
PARTICIPANTS SO BE SAFE BE
VIGILANT STAY ENGAGED THANK YOU.
AND HAVE A WONDERFUL REST. OF
THE EVENING. WE ARE ADJOURNED.